fall to the coveted 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
to the house calendar for today an
executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and
selected legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporariously listening
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by a zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with the house
rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and then rescheduled please
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presence please
also state whether there's anybody in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required on the right to know
law
okay keith you're on
all right clerk will call the role uh
representative john hunt i am here alone
representative john patuck
i am here alone
representative jason osborne
representative keith hammond that's me
president alone
representative max abramson
representative abramson
yeah i don't see him on
representative body ham
representative ham
you're muted
i'm mute bonnie
okay
i'm here and i'm alone
okay noted
representative joseph de palma
representative palmer i don't see joe
yeah he might his class
representative jeffrey griesen
i am here and alone
representative don johnson
i'm here alone at the moment with my
dogs but my daughters are upstairs
zooming so you may see them walk through
okay representative paul terry
representative terry
representative christie bartlett
i am president and i'm alone in this
room
okay representative richard abell
richard abel uh here i'm by myself uh my
wife is also in the house
chris herbert
representative herbert
representative connie van houten
i'm here and obviously there's a barking
dog with me but there's no person with
me
am i saying your last name right how is
it howton
yes van houden it's out out
out okay good to
know thank you representative tina fargo
i'm here and i'm alone in the room my
husband is in the house
representative joyce weston
i'm here and i'm alone in the
house representative jane value
here and i'm home alone
representative anita burroughs
i'm here i'm alone in the room my
husband is in the house
and lastly representative chris mcaleer
um i'm here my wife is stirring around
in the background
that representative abram abramson has
joined us okay
i'm here and i'm all
okay
that's the role we have uh
four absentees and uh the rest present
uh keith did you pick me up yesterday
when i came in late
um
oh yeah i did
thank you i haven't submitted that yet
but it's you're on the list from
yesterday
thank you sir
thank you
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
uh house bill 462.
and
will if you're there can you raise your
hand
there he is
okay thank you
and
why can't i
can you upgrade him to him because i'm
i'm not able to upgrade him
oops sorry i may not have um promoted
you there there is okay excitement of
the discussion
okay
all right uh
good morning representative evantine
you're still muted
now you're good
good morning mr chairman
good morning
my name is will infantine i represent uh
hillsborough 13 which is ward 6 in
manchester
i'll do my best here this is very
foreign to all of us uh
so i'll do my best i'm used to sitting
in front of all of you speaking so um
i'm here to introduce uh house bill 462.
relative to lean assessments by
condominium associations
in order to
explain this and backtrack a few years
a few years ago i submitted a piece of
legislation which was passed and is now
law
it allows condominium associations to
place a priority lean
on
a condominium unit for up to six months
worth of
um
condominium fees
sorry sorry it's a bit of this piece of
legislation
it will would you just hold on a second
i'm not able to make out they could file
for bankruptcy and all of that he might
want to turn off his video and his audio
will be better i think that's a great
idea yeah well your your uh your audio
is a little rough yeah okay
go ahead
mr clerk is that better
no uh so sounds that sounds better to me
yeah
i'll call in
uh that's not better
okay
so far so good
okay i i will backtrack a little bit um
thank you
a few years do you have a testimony will
do can you can submit this written
testimony
i do not okay
it's fine no problem
uh i want to stay within my three or
four minutes here so i'm going to go
quick
years ago submitted a piece of
legislation that allowed condominium
associations place a six-month priority
lien
on a unit owner's unit for past due
condo fees
it was done uh so because people would
not pay the condo fee association would
struggle
um
financially and then in the event of a
bankruptcy or such the
condo fees would just go away they would
not be paid so we submitted this piece
of legislation which would make six
months worth of condo fees be priority
to the lien uh and uh first the bankers
association had a problem with it and um
didn't want anything to do with it
thought it would be detrimental to
people getting loans in new hampshire
that didn't happen
they realized after a while that a
strong association where association had
enough money to pay their maintenance
upkeep
capital improvements was good
for everyone and they agreed to uh go
along with the bill that's my knowledge
there have been no issues
over the last number of years since this
has been um
law one of the things that did come up
prior to this passing was that whether
or not this was constitutional can you
interrupt a contract place a piece of
legislation
uh in in the middle of what was already
a contract opportunity a mortgagee
a lender and a borrower
and we agreed that that was correct it
can't be done so the law that was passed
was only for bill only for mortgages
that um
were
taken out after the law was passed so
that is what is in place and that's what
happened a number of years ago
this bill well may read the same is
significantly different and i want to be
clear as to what it's about
it allows a condo association to be able
to get a priority lean
and then foreclose
on the unit
why is this being requested well when
things were very bad a number of years
ago mortgage companies would let
mortgage go for three or four years
and not do anything
they would not foreclose they wouldn't
do anything because they didn't want to
have a bad loan on their books
more often not the owners had vacated
the property so the associations had to
winterize it but still heat it for
adjacent
units
and nothing would happen they would stay
there and that was not good for the
association
so this mechanism would allow
a congress association to go forward the
lien and then process a foreclosure
now the unit owner still has all the
remedies available to themselves um such
as
um to make good on it make payments of
bankruptcy all those different things
the association just had the ability to
do that now when they if they would
foreclose they would only be entitled to
their condo fees
any fees for illegal to process a
foreclosure but they wouldn't be resp
they wouldn't take the rest of the money
that would go for the mortgage holder
again this would be a situation where
this would only be
this bill is enacted at 1-122 this would
only be for mortgages that are put in
place after that
uh i am an insurance agent i'm not a
lawyer or a banker and there are people
step behind me that are lawyers and
bankers to speak about this
but really all came down to the fact
that this concept of a zombie mortgage
where the mortgage companies wouldn't do
anything and units would just sit idle
for years
i want to be brief mr chairman so i will
accept questions but again if you have
if it is of a
uh legal nature or bankers anchor nature
i would ask you to hold those questions
until
uh the other individuals testify thank
you mr chairman
all right um okay no problem is there
any questions yes we do have a couple
questions uh representative terry you
may inquire
mr chairman only to note uh
for the record that um i have joined the
committee meeting at 9 11 a.m
um i am alone in the room my wife is in
the house thank you okay great
uh
representative van halton
thank you mr chair good morning will and
thank you for taking my question i would
like to begin first by stating that i am
a condo owner and resident which is why
my dog was barking they're apparently
going to paint the hall today during our
hearing
so um i have a couple of questions
though is this is an actual for coat
foreclosure in other words there will be
other liens that are subordinate or that
are
take priority over this for instance if
i'm foreclosed today
um would my real estate taxes be the top
lien
in the condo
uh you're there well
i don't have the answer to that question
uh i know i
my
it would only be my belief that property
taxes would be primary the condo fee
secondary and the fees and then the
mortgage
yeah i have gary lined up to be the next
speaker so he can answer that question
is there anybody else any other yes
follow up please yeah
thank you very much um
so this would be an actual foreclosure
and if i were to foreclose this would be
on my on my record as as far as credit
going forward is that correct
yes that is correct but it's like any
other foreclosure notice that is
received the individual has the ability
to um rectify the payments make a some
kind of uh
plan with the association whatever it's
not a beta complete um
the same way it wouldn't be if your
mortgage company
would initiate a foreclosure
and one more follow-up please if i may
miss
a question of inquiry
thank you and so would this trigger like
an auction or a a
mortgagee sale or something of that sort
is that would that be the next step
should this actually go to foreclosure
it could representative but i think the
lawyer and the banker that
will speak after me will explain to you
what has happened in in reality
is that if people have abandoned the
properties yes they would go to a
foreclosure if not usually the mortgage
company will step in and rectify the
situation
and uh refinance somehow to
with the uh unit owner
so payments are made and and the issue
goes away
thank you well i appreciate that
thank you representative okay any other
questions for the sponsor saying none
i think you will um all right so uh gary
dario you're you're
you're next
hi good morning i would also note that
representative herbert has joined us
make a note
good thank you go ahead gary
hi good morning everyone and uh thank
you for your time in hearing me on this
bill
you've seen versions of this bill before
so in the interest of time um i won't
give a long explanation of why this is
needed but the short answer is that
associations run only on the money that
they collect by assessments and so when
they run into long-term delinquency
units they really struggle in terms of
providing the proper maintenance for the
property the proper insurance for the
property because without the unit owner
money coming in they're unable to pay
their bills so it has become really
important uh the problem is that even
with all the law that we have including
um as will just mentioned the priority
lean law
after we perfect a priority lien after
we go to court after the court issues a
judgment in a case
to the extent that the judgment isn't
paid right now in new hampshire we're
sort of left in limbo where the
delinquency continues but the
association has no further moves to make
with the exception of a sheriff's sale
i've done sheriff's sales
they tend to not move the situation
forward because
if any bidders actually show up and
usually they don't if they show up what
they find out is that the unit owner
under a sharp sale procedure has a one
year right of redemption
um they are also taking subject to the
mortgage and when you add you know both
of those conditions people don't feel
comfortable trying to buy this as an
investment property
of the some
17 states
in the country that have priority liens
for condo associations new hampshire is
at present the only one that can't
foreclose on
so really what we're asking for is just
the ability
as we do elsewhere
to be able to bring a long-term
condominium unit delinquency to a
resolution if the case pushes that far
um now to
fill in the gaps a little bit with what
will mention i can tell you as a as a
condominium practitioner who's done
nothing but this type of law for the
past 18 years
um in states where there is a
foreclosure remedy for the association
and i practice in in one of those um
more than 97
of my cases
were resolved short of foreclosure
and so in reality what i can tell you is
that what happens is that the
possibility of the foreclosure the fact
that that event could happen
doesn't make that event happen
what it what it makes happen in reality
is for people to resolve the issue one
way or the other if the unit owner is at
the unit then they tend to resolve it
because they want to resolve it before
they lose the unit if it's one of the
many cases that will mentioned where the
unit already has vacated the premises
because for whatever reason they can't
afford to live there anymore and they're
on their way and now the association is
stuck with a vacant unit in those cases
the bank will make a business decision
under the existing process and that
wouldn't change if this bill passes
the first mortgage holder gets notices
two of them prior to the filing of suit
and then they are kept abreast of what
happens in the suit that's in court
because they're named as a party in
interest not a defendant
but a party in interest so they can
remain on top of the situation as it
moves through the court and then finally
if the judgment issues and isn't paid
then they also would get notice of the
foreclosure so there's no surprise
foreclosure from the standpoint of the
first mortgage holder
and so what happens is in those cases
those rare cases less than three percent
um where foreclosure is an option
but the situation is not otherwise
resolved then the bank will make a
business decision
and if they feel it's in their best
interest to retain the property then
they will simply contact us the way they
otherwise might and say we're going to
pay these condo fees because we don't
want to see this unit go to foreclosure
and that's really all the association
needs so when that happens we make that
agreement
and everybody proceeds
in cases where the bank's business
decision is that it would actually be
better for this property to get
foreclosed and move on with a new owner
then sometimes they won't respond at all
but uh oftentimes to be perfectly honest
with you
i will be contacted by first mortgage
holders who say i see what's going on i
see what you're doing and um you know go
ahead just make sure after the
foreclosure you send us our check for
everything that you're not entitled to
keep and as will mention all the
associations keeping is priority lien
related money so when this piece of real
estate sells the lion's share of those
proceeds are still going to the mortgage
holder anyway
oh and i should mention with respect to
the questions that came up
this does not affect
tax liens on the property those would
still be above that of the association
so we're not tipping the apple car in
that sense
that would remain the same also
i know of no condominium law
practitioners that engage in credit
reporting relative to these unit owners
so i know you know with public notice
and such a foreclosure the information's
kind of out there but for what it's
worth i know our firm doesn't and all of
the other firms that i know of that
focus uh in condominium law i don't know
of anyone
who's making reports to the credit
reporting agencies over the uh
delinquent assessment situations
okay uh representative van houden does
have a question
actually thank you you you have more
directly addressed what i was going for
i really wanted to know about the
finality of this if it really did
parallel foreclosure on a uh on a
separate home uh and just another quick
question i believe you're with cai if i
remember the initials correctly would
you clarify the group that you're
representing for us please certainly so
the community associations institute is
a nationwide non-profit whose only goal
is to make association living
better and more desirable
they have regional chapters under their
national umbrella
new hampshire
not surprisingly falls into the new
england chapter
and then in each state they have a
legislative action committee which is a
group of volunteers that monitors
legislation impacting um you know
condominium and association living and
for the state of new hampshire i am
currently chairing that committee
thank you
okay uh uh representative mccleary
mcleary
um yeah
would this
include not only condos but like
subdivision associations or all those
types of associations
in uh doesn't necessarily have to be a
condo would that be correct
uh so this bill actually speaks to
condominiums at present it would be part
of 356b
uh rsa 356b which governs condominiums
uh it is my understanding that as yet
homeowner associations do not have their
own statute
we have seen a draft of one and uh i
believe it will be proposed again and
i'm pretty sure that at some point in
the future homeowner associations will
have their own statute the way
condominiums do and cooperatives do but
at present this would be part of 356b
which is a condominium specific issue
any other questions
uh thank you very much gary
okay so then we also have from cai we
have um
uh wes blair
so if wes if you want to speak raise
your hand other i see you down at the
bottom so don't don't raise your hand
because you'll move on me okay here we
go
and
getting promoted there you go
and you're muted just so you know
is that better
sounds great thank you thank you for uh
uh listening to me this morning uh i am
what my name is wes blair i'm a senior
vice president with brookline bank in
massachusetts
i've been an active member of cai
for 20 plus years
i'm a member of the massachusetts
legislative action committee
and
gary asked me if i would uh add a little
bit of color to the experience that
my bank has had over the years with
regards to the priority lien we have in
massachusetts
i can go back i've been with the bank
for almost 30 years uh i started our
we i started our lending program to
condominium associations making loans to
them for capital improvements um at the
same time i've also run our residential
lending program at the bank uh up until
about five years ago
and um
so
i have i think probably a fairly unique
uh view of the priority lien
situation
i can tell you that when the
massachusetts priority lien was proposed
myself as well as just about every
banker in massachusetts said this is
terrible it's going to create havoc in
the industry and and
this is not a good thing
turned out to be quite the opposite
frankly i can tell you that in our in
all the years that i ran our residential
side
we never lost a unit because of a
priority lien
um
the key is that we were always notified
it gave us a chance to look at our
situation sometimes as gary had said we
we would we would uh go back to the
association council and say just keep us
informed and we'll be at the at the
foreclosure to bid and protect our
interests um other times we've said to
we've said to council look
send us the bill we'll pay it we'll keep
it current and we'll deal with our
borrower
that's been very successful for us over
the years and i think that
about
25 years ago
we actually started making loans as i
mentioned two associations and one of
the things that really allowed us to do
that was that we had the confidence that
associations were going to be able to
take action and collect their fees and
it's those fees that make my
loan program for associations work
because my collateral in that side of
things is not the um
real estate it's the cash flow of the
association and so clearly my concern is
how strong is that is that that that
cash flow with the ability to actually
foreclose you know it's one thing to to
to give an association the um
right to do and attach a unit but if you
don't give them the teeth to actually
take action just as gary said
a problem can sit there for years and
that that's a drain on the cash flow and
and the financial resources of the
association not to mention that um
it can also be damaging to the physical
plant of the association somebody
abandons their unit
the lender doesn't step up and the next
thing you know the temperature drops
below freezing the pipes freeze they
burst now you've got a real problem in
the association things like that have
happened uh
all over the northeast and i can tell
you that
the best way to prevent that is to make
sure that the cash flow of the
association is strong and i think i
would i would urge you to to
to to uh pass this so that associations
have the the teeth to be able to act uh
and um protect themselves and to protect
the unit owners
okay thank you uh any questions from
committee
members
okay saying none
i'm going to now uh
um
change the pace a little bit here
and so ryan i am now going to bring you
up and ryan hill represents the new
hampshire bankers association who is in
opposition to the belt
good morning ryan
good morning everyone it's uh great to
see everyone um wish we were in person
uh
thank you for the opportunity to uh
speak to the group today and um i'd just
like to mention representative
i really like your tie being a skier so
thank you for sharing
um
chairman hunt honourable members of the
house commerce committee for the record
my name is ryan hale i'm vice president
government relations for the new
hampshire bankers association
new hampshire bankers represents 38
member banks
which employ nearly six thousand
employees
i come before the committee today to
provide testimony and opposition to
house bill 462
for the following reasons uh as
introduced
and as the sponsor has indicated hb 462
would increase the condominiums
associations party lien rights by giving
volunteer boards
uh the right to foreclose upon and evict
a condo unit uh owner for unpaid
assessment fees regardless of the amount
owed um either as it as current law
says
it can be up to six months of
unpaid fees uh so this proposal does go
beyond that 2010 compromise the sponsor
pointed to
um which did create the existing
statutory pri uh priority lien rights
for the unpaid assessment fees
and allowed the uh condominium
associations to require owners to escrow
um six months of fees uh
as the sponsor pointed out this isn't
the first time uh most recently hb
uh
uh 436 which this committee heard back
in i believe it was 2019
was voted on 19 nothing in expedient to
legislate
uh
the condominium associations i think
it's important to point out already have
less drastic options at their disposal
again part of that compromise back in
2010 was um giving them ability to
require escrowing about uh of up to six
months of unpaid uh
assessment fees um
additionally they can limit uh or
eliminate access to common areas such as
jim's pools and parking to encourage a
unit order to pay their fair share
um if it acted uh we see some unattended
consequences occurring
specifically
giving the condo board
the right to foreclose upon a unit
could potentially could increase or will
increase a lender's risk
associated with condominium lending
this could result in a borrow and
borrowers paying higher interest rates
to account for the added risk um or
limit access lending more generally
we we see these consequences could have
an impact that extends again beyond
banking industry
and could make condominiums the less
attractive options uh for first-time
home buyers which condominiums are
generally viewed as affordable workforce
housing for and sometimes first-time
homeowners
entry into the market
and ultimately this could reduce values
of condos and potentially could apparent
already anemic housing market so we all
know big issue and remains here in new
hampshire
the low occupancy rate
um additionally the timing of this
legislation runs counter to current
efforts to keep individuals in their
homes
during the pandemic i i always like to
point out the great work that banks have
done to help keep uh homeowners in their
homes uh providing uh forbearance and
payment deferrals um
those can go up to 18 months um
the response you know
our our members response bank's response
um
you know has been immediate um
and uh you know we see uh the good work
that they're doing um
however hb 462 we see round encounter to
this um by giving the effort of
associate or giving association's
ability to foreclose on you know we're
sending homeowners kind of mixed
messages
we understand
uh the difficulties uh unpaid assessment
fees do create
but this change is not the answer
especially when they do have other
options currently at their disposal as i
mentioned
uh requiring that unit owners uh
um escrow up to the six months um to
provide that cushion to provide that
security um
one one um point i also would like to
make it and the sponsor had mentioned
that um this is only would be only for
contracts moving forward um i looked
through the legislation and i did check
with legal and i in the build i couldn't
see anywhere where it does
would point to just future contracts not
going back in time
so i think there is a concern there um
and i do it legal uh um we do have an
attorney on the call today
to answer any legal questions that i may
be uh unable to answer so
in closing um as we had in the past we
would urge the committee to vote against
uh 462 and move to inexpedia to
legislate as the committee has done to
some of the legislation in the past
thank you for your consideration and i'd
be happy to take any questions at this
time uh we do have questions
see some hands okay representative
bartlett is first
thank you mr chair thank you for coming
before us mr hale
um question i've got is
how often do condominium associations
actually require six months in escrow
which would be
quite a lot of money to be able to get
up front when they purchase in addition
to a down payment when they purchase
a condominium
that's a great question and
unfortunately uh representative bartlett
i don't have the answer i mean i think
it's a it's a decision of each
individual association but um given the
fact that they do have that ability to
to request it it does create a you know
i think less drastic option um than
allowing a condo association to initiate
the foreclosure um
you know
i think one of the big concerns we have
with it is
uh you know
the the unpaid assessment fees could be
a matter of a few hundred bucks with a
few thousand bucks compared to the rest
of the bank holds which you know could
be several hundred thousand dollars um
and yet the this bill would allow the
um the association to foreclose on it
again i apologize i don't have the
answer to that i think that might be an
answer but um i think the condo
associations would have the answer to
that question
but it is at their disposal it is an
option they do have
um mr chair could we
ask
could we maybe ask somebody we do have
another person uh speak coming up to
speak uh so dean dean you'll make sure
you answer that question for them thank
you dean okay so uh you all set then
christy okay yes all right uh so uh next
question is from john patusek
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
ryan for coming before us and thank you
for the uh
the thing want to tie my
my question is basically does this
differ does this build differ virtually
in any way from the one we itl two years
ago
um a little bit in the sense that i
believe the one um a couple years ago
increased the amount of fees that they
could uh to add i believe that one
allowed auctioneer fees to be added to
the lien um the way we read this one is
it it does that additional legal fees
but um quite simply
does allow
for initiating of the foreclosure which
436 also had the initiation of the
foreclosure aspect to the legislation
thank you for the question
thank you welcome okay uh representative
mccleary
all right thank you uh mr chairman um
the small amount of of money that
could be involved here is is there any
way that you could see that a
committee condo committee could could be
vindictive in using this to uh
discriminate uh in any way
uh you know just uh give you know hassle
people that they might not like is that
a possibility here
i you know you know i think
i think it does open the door for that
you know there there is potential for
abuse we do see there that there is that
potential again um you know i think
there's different dynamics with the
different condo boards but i think
it does open that up as i think
ultimately it does open that up as a
possibility
you know someone that you know i think
there it could create a scenario where
someone that misses the fee misses some
fees here and there pays them misses
some fees here and there then pays them
ultimately this would allow the condo
association to at some point put their
foot down and just
go to the board and initiate the
foreclosure process
okay uh representative abramson
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um during uh maybe you covered this
earlier but during a condo foreclosure
is the bank paying the condo fees while
it's uh
before the auction occurs
um
that's a great question um
i i have an attorney on the line that
may be able to answer that but to my
understanding no i think it would rely
on the
um the condo owner i think the only way
likely and and i may
i think again
attorney beatle our legal is on the on
this call may be able to answer this
better but my understanding that would
result if those that if the fees were
escrowed the bank could then uh pay
those fees
and uh follow up for the question may
inquire
and uh
the arrearages in other words the condo
fees that might have accumulated before
the uh people walked away from it said
the same
i would believe so but i can i can
follow up with uh the committee uh with
answers to that all right sure thing
thank you for the question okay
representative burroughs
um thank you and thank you for um taking
my question um
mr house wondering would the bill be
more palatable to the to the banking
industry if there is a minimum amount of
money owed by the uh condo owners um
because we said their possibility of
foreclosure with just a couple of
hundred dollars it would if just for
example we said the minimum would be
five thousand dollars
um again i you know i i would have to go
back to uh our folks but i do feel that
um i think just a simple fact of
allowing a condo association to
foreclose on
you know whatever that six month let's
say that maximum or six months you know
um what the bank
risk far outweighs that small six months
of
fees let's say
um it's a thousand dollars so that's six
thousand dollars in comparison you know
that bank holds you know 100 potentially
a couple hundred thousand dollar
mortgage on that so i think that's a
real concern and you know through the
foreclosure sale what what is the return
you know so the condo association
because they have the priority lien
would be um
would be um paid first
you know what what is left goes to the
other elite you know the bank um but you
know through condo associations the last
number i heard was in foreclosures
this was a few years ago but i believe
it was a 60 cents on the dollar so there
would be there could be a loss
so i think that really is the risk that
we're concerned with so thank you for
your question thank you
okay see no more questions uh you're all
set and um i'll now invite dean lemon to
uh to testify
thank you representative hunt and
committee members uh i appreciate the
opportunity i am also with uh cai new
england like gary dario
so on its face this bill uh is the
ability to foreclose a priority lien but
i think the way we need to think about
this bill is one to preserve and protect
the financial integrity of condos and
this is because the existing priority
lean law doesn't go far enough as gary
stated all the other states with
priority liens have the ability to
foreclose on those liens
and that's important because it gives
condos
some leverage
to get a payment out of an owner
or if an owner can't do that
to force their mortgage company
to do it for them
with the idea being the the mortgage
company can add that on to the the
principal balance and get repaid in time
and of course banks have a greater
financial wherewithal than non-profit
condominium associations
now the ability to foreclose or excuse
me that actually foreclosing on an owner
is going to be exceedingly rare i would
put it at well under one percent of all
cases
and it's important to know
that
a foreclosure is only going to happen if
the if the mortgage company if the bank
wants it to happen
this idea that a condo will foreclose
over three hundred dollars or a thousand
dollars
is a red herring that is i have never in
my life over
12 years foreclosed on an amount so low
and it's simply not going to happen
we're talking about the exceedingly rare
situation where
an owner cannot has abandoned the unit
has
no ability to pay
and the bank for whatever reason will
not respond to our notices these are the
situations we're talking about
i have a case right now where the the in
um in nashua where the bank finally
foreclosed after years
of the owner after the owner vacated
the owner
was gone was not paying every month
unpaid fees unpaid fees unpaid fees and
finally after over two years the bank
finally foreclosed and my client could
do nothing
the termination of services ability that
um mr hale referenced that's that's some
leverage but when the owner is not there
it is no leverage whatsoever
so
in this when you're dealing with condos
they need every dollar to be paid out of
their budget
they need something like uh the ability
to foreclose in these rare circumstances
um and in the the everyday circumstances
you just need some leverage to make
banks pay you
when owners cannot
and again the banks put that right onto
the principal they usually make owners
pay it out of escrow payments like they
do for property taxes and in time they
will get paid
um
and and just to address some of the the
general allegations made by uh mr hale
uh regarding higher interest rates
uh reduced property values i would ask
the banking lobby to show us the proof
of that it certainly has not happened in
massachusetts and i'm not aware of it
happening in all the other states with
priority lean foreclosure laws as mr
blair said it really enhances property
values because you know
the condo has the financial wherewithal
to keep up the buildings to replace
roofs to replace siding so this like i
said at the outset this is not a
foreclosure bill alone this is about
protecting condominium finances and i
thank you for your time i know uh
representative bartlett had a question
for mr hale that was not answered if you
could just refresh my memory on that
please
go ahead representative
thank you for remembering um
i'm wondering how often it is i mean one
of the arguments that the bankers are
saying is that the condominiums um
associations have the ability to
escrow up to six months of condo fees
when somebody purchases a unit do you
have any idea how often that requirement
is actually um
in place
i don't have a figure on that but i can
tell you with 100 confidence i've never
seen it happen i've never seen a bank
say well
good thing we we escrow these funds
here's a check for six months i've just
never seen it ever
okay thank you you're welcome
and and just one final note i'm sorry if
i'm overstepping my bounds here but a
foreclosure is only going to happen if
the mortgage company allows it to happen
and that's because they're getting all
these notices and they're making a
business decision this is not something
that happens in secret or behind closed
doors this is something the bank knows
about from before suit during suit and
after suit and it doesn't happen
overnight it's going to be a six month
or more process
uh representative van houghton you have
a question
yes thank you and thank you for taking
my question um i'm looking at both the
condominium act as well as the bill and
between the two i'm having some
questions
um one is
a foreclosure can happen for six months
of rare ages even if some of the past
due
bills are already caught up i heard that
testimony earlier and i'm not sure if i
got that correct
i'm not sure that is correct
if a suit's going to be filed it's
typically going to be when the owner
owes the six months of fees or maybe a
few months thereafter probably a few
months there after because you're going
to record a lien
and let the owner know um and if if you
are foreclosing it could be any amount
by that time you know perhaps by the
time you get a judgment against them
it's ballooned to 12 months but you're
still only the priority lien is still
only going to be the six months
if for some reason the owner had paid it
down to one or two months i don't see
foreclosure as an option at that point
because there's no reason to you know
the arrearage has been paid down
um follow-up please the question may
inquire
um another representative earlier asked
about the idea of having say a five
thousand dollar uh minimum what are your
thoughts on something of that sort
well it's hard to set a a hard minimum
because some some
condo fees are a hundred dollars per
month others are five or six hundred
dollars
per month
so you know to me six months you want to
think about it in months as opposed to
dollars
um so i guess i could foresee a bill
that that required at least six months
or or some other amount to be owed
in order to foreclose but to set it at a
dollar value i think is is difficult
just because fees can vary so widely
thank you
uh representative abramson
thank you mr chair and uh same question
as before does the uh during the process
of condo foreclosure is the bank paying
either the condo fees or the arrearages
it's rather rare once in
in massachusetts anyway you'll sometimes
see a bank pay the priority lien
and then start paying monthly until they
foreclose because they don't want us to
keep on
restarting the process to foreclose so
they actually save money by saving the
legal fees so
in
new hampshire it's rather rare at this
point in time to ever see uh uh
the bank
pay monthly until they foreclose and and
the reason is because they don't have to
uh we're limited to one priority lean at
a time and they know we can't foreclose
on it so that the banks can drag their
feet as long as they're so inclined to
do
uh and the association is left holding
the bag and suffering
all right thank you
okay
um seeing no more hands so we can move
on thank you very much dean uh so tom
parasol
and i'm gonna ask you to unmute
tom
okay
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is tom
prasal representing
the mortgage bankers brokers association
of new hampshire
i had not signed up to speak however i
did want to i think ryan did a great job
outlining our opposition to the bill
so
with that i do have a 10 o'clock hearing
to go to um and i think ryan did a fine
job okay okay
uh dave i i promoted you but now i see
you didn't actually uh want to speak
because do you you have anything you
want to say anything or
actually um yeah i'm going to ask you to
unmute
you mr chairman members of the committee
dave collins on behalf of new hampshire
credit unions
again not intended to speak i think ryan
covered it
but i would point out that there was a
statement made by the advocates of the
bill that i found
somewhat interesting and that is that
this is this bill is a measure
um to provide leverage to make the banks
pay
uh when the dollars are not forthcoming
from the condo owner
and i think that's clearly just a
shifting of the responsibility
and perhaps is not uh appropriate
given the fact that for the in this case
the bank the financial institution has
the financial wherewithal it's a
shifting of responsibilities i would
suggest that the problem needs to be
addressed at its source
thank you fair enough representative
herbert i see your hand is up
thank you chairman hunt
i have a question i guess
and in terms i i think i heard the word
forbearance
in in the sense that uh somebody was
going to
uh not not
will be uh carry the charges
uh until
you know some sort of resolution is
is made
uh and the way i i see it it looks as
though the forbearance is gonna have to
be made by
the condo association not the bank
and the bank is the lender
so i i would think that the
the
responsibility
goes back to the lender
and to make the association
eat the uh
uh the money
it
to me sounds a little uh backwards
so
um
there are risks of course being a bank
and making the loan
based on whatever collateral they think
uh that condo
represents
so that was entirely their decision
and it's not the association's decision
so i think uh i think in in this case
the uh the responsibility uh especially
when you
throw in the word forbearance
uh should fall upon uh the the person or
entity that uh uh made the loan on the
collateral so
that's that's just an observation and i
and i think that
would you believe yes uh-huh the condo
association did not make the loan okay
and so we're running out of time here so
uh thank you very much and thank you
dave and i'm going to close the public
hearing on
house bill 462
and
now
okay so the next bill is
[Music]
466. and
uh
so 466 i got
the sponsor
is uh representative reed and there she
is and i'm gonna
representative reed and
good morning representative reed
i've done mute yep there you go okay
yeah i've never been on that side of it
this way and
i it actually kicks you out and let me
add you back so there's a delay i
apologize
uh thank you mr chair um for the record
my name is ellen reed i represent
rockingham 17 new market new fields um
this bill
is actually a reintroduction
introduction of a bill that i had put in
last year which
with an amendment
passed this committee i i think
unanimously was on the consent calendar
past the consent calendar and it was one
of the
many uh casualties over in the senate of
covid
um
so
the way i put this bill in this way is
as it was amended out of this committee
um it was not the way i
personally preferred but i thought it
would be the way that you all would be
the most amenable so what this bill says
in its current amended form
amended according to last year
is simply that a um a unit owner who can
vote a board member who can vote on
contracts if that unit owner has
um some sort of business that the
the association might contract out to
that that person must recuse themselves
from voting on
awarding that contract to their own
business i think that is a pretty
standard
uh procedure in in in terms of dealing
with conflict of interest for most
situations for whatever reason um
in new hampshire law we never specified
that that had to be the case
and so the reason that i originally put
this bill in is because it does have and
has had real world significant real
world impacts so i originally put this
in for a constituent
um and i have since learned even more
about the situation
um in newmarket there is a condo
association a condo
complex
um where the person who owns the
majority of the units also owns a large
property management company
and as i've talked to quite a few of the
uh renters in that association i've come
to find out that
not only is that property management
company the one that's contracted out
too but that they
they haven't done anything really in the
sense of assisting their their tenants
but they have
um repeatedly done had lots of contracts
awarded to them for
what has been viewed as mostly
unnecessary work ripping out trees
putting new trees in ripping those out
putting them in again and meanwhile the
the issues that the tenants have within
their own units
goes largely unaddressed uh and while
that has happened so this this unit
owner who has this property management
company and then votes on the board to
award the contract for property
management to his own company
while that has happened and all of these
jobs unneces largely unnecessary jobs as
i understand them are being done
the housing um the hoa feed that the
tenants are having to pay through their
rent um has incrementally gone up over
the years as well
um and it come to find out that in this
particular situation this person doesn't
only do it with this particular
condo complex but actually is involved
in owns either some or majority of some
12 other complexes who also contract out
through his property management company
so it's become something of a business
model
because of this loophole we have
so my understanding is that well
i can say from remembering from the
hearing last year
i believe everybody on this committee as
it was uh
created last year
uh agreed with the
principle or the intent of
making sure we didn't have this conflict
of interest problem
the only real concern that had come up
and which is why it was amended to the
current version you have before you
was the potential for say a single unit
owner
um or even someone who owns several
units who maybe has a plow or has a
small business and if that person is
willing to do superior work for the the
lowest price available why shouldn't
they be able to
go ahead and do that which was a
sensible uh argument um so the
the amendment last year which is now the
bill this year simply requires the
person to recuse themselves i personally
would prefer to just have a dollar limit
on the contracts available rather than
say just recusal
or possibly both because
my fear is especially in the case of the
person who apparently i'm dealing with
in newmarket and in other areas here
if someone is powerful enough to own the
majority of units uh in an association
and
and otherwise have a big property
management company i fear that just them
recusing themselves may not necessarily
lead to just the best decisions because
that person also likely has a lot of
connections on the board
um and through just personal
relationships may be able to get the
contract anyway so um that's
personally i would like to see in
addition to the recusal just some like
max dollar amount
um which would help protect say the the
individual guy who just happens to have
a plow on his truck and is willing to to
plow for the association
versus um
versus the kind of situation i'm dealing
with here with my constituents but
that's that's essentially it i either in
either case whether it's this version or
some other amendment um to be added to
it i would just highly
uh ask that this committee understand
the importance of this conflict of
interest
issue and uh pass some sort of
measure to deal with the conflict of
interest and and i'm open for any
questions
so we do have a couple uh representative
bartlett here up first
thank you mr chair thanks for coming to
see us again um representative reed
if if i recall this
last year
the concern we had was the really small
uh condo associations is that correct
um i don't i i have to admit my
ignorance in what constitutes a small
condo association versus a large one the
one that is in new market that i am
dealing with as you know a matter of
dealing with my constituents in this
issue has maybe i would guess a hundred
ish uh units
so i
okay all right follow up continue yes so
um
so i think that
that our the reason that we wanted the
amendment in there was for the you know
like the four units
kind of condo association where if one
of them like you say has a plow on and
that was why
we wanted it to be amended to just allow
them to recuse because i think
we were concerned
with the kind of issue that you've
brought up
and i just wanted to to clarify why we
had asked
regarding the um recusal because we just
felt it was un
as i recall we thought it was
unrealistic
in a very small association where
you know
there's only two or three on the board
and one of them happens
to plow the the driveway that
that that could affect the management of
the
of the association
um if i recall you're you're correct
representative bartlett um i didn't
remember specifically the size of the
association being um the main issue was
more about well what's the harm of if
you have a unit owner that just has a
small business or a plow and they they
are providing the best service at the
best price
why shouldn't they be able to go ahead
and do that and i don't find any issue
with that at all so i i was happy that
the committee moved forward on the bill
in any form and and i had only mentioned
that
that perhaps recusal in a big situation
like this might not be enough um and if
the committee was amenable to it i would
personally like to see an additional
piece added and it may include something
along the lines of the size of the
association like you mentioned or it may
just be a dollar limit let's say a 5 000
or 10 000 limit they cannot contract
with the unit owner
for more than 10 000 in a year which i
think is a low enough amount to prevent
the
um
to prevent uh
incentivizing
this kind of behavior in a way that has
led to the current situation where this
person owns a majority of units or
significant amount of units in 12
different associations all of which are
around the same size and owns this giant
uh property management company and is
just essentially making money hand over
fist and i happen to know what happens
to be well into the millions
because um he has this kind of conflict
of interest business model
well would you believe that
for the question require i'm sorry thank
you mr chair
would you believe that the committee is
hesitant to put dollar amounts on into
law because they don't stand up over
long periods of time
i would believe it i'm only suggesting
um just as this committee was creative
enough to come up with an amendment that
made everybody happy that perhaps
considering the fact
that a person of that kind of power that
i'm talking about might be able to
influence board members even if they
themselves are recused might also be an
issue so perhaps like you first
suggested instead of a dollar amount
putting a size restriction
um
and
if they're under that size restriction
having them recused if they're over that
size restriction having it just they
can't contract out
that would also be a totally fine
amendment in my opinion
thank you
representative burroughs has a question
yes thank you for taking my question um
representative reed um how widespread is
this problem i know you're talking about
a constituent in a particular individual
using this business model um does this
extend beyond this individual do you
have information
i i don't have any information to that
this is all i've been able this was
again brought to me by constituents
something i was unaware of in my own
town and
because uh i'm engaging
in this issue through this very specific
problem i haven't i don't have any
knowledge or even a way to know how to
gain the knowledge of it being a problem
with other individuals um
having said that it's just good conflict
of interest policy right this is a basic
thing that we believe in that you can't
vote on the
board or entity that then awards the
contract for your own business that's
just standard for us
follow-up please for the question
inquire yes thank you um
might it not make sense for this issue
to be dealt with in the condominium's
bylaws rather than through legislation
i mean
it could be but i suppose the problem
that you're running into is once
somebody has that level of power you're
running into the same conflict of
interest problem how can you then amend
the bylaws if the people who are voting
for it are
in majority the one so you were talking
about in this particular situation
majority owner
so if if they own the majority of units
they have majority control in the vote
and how can you possibly amend the
bylaws
against that person's will
thank you thank you for that
big point
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for uh
taking my question
uh so this bill was thoroughly reviewed
by this committee it was a last term it
sounds like correct
what analysis was done
as far as other states having similar
provisions
i personally didn't do any analysis if
this committee did such an analysis uh
then
that would be a question for the
committee members or committee assistant
okay uh seeing no more questions we
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
and
i know okay so i don't have anybody else
in support so uh dean lennon i know i
kept you up here so dean you want to
tell us why you're opposed to this bill
yes thank you representative hunt um
my primary concern with this bill is
that unit owners are not um select or
not approving contractors that that's a
job by the board
uh unit owners are voting on amendments
unit owners are electing people unit
owners are
um
you know sometimes making improvement
votes but they are not
picking the plowing contract or they're
not picking the roofing contractor so
uh that that's concern number one does
this law even do anything uh the second
concern would be that the proposal is to
legislate a very unique issue that's
happening
at one condo and i don't think laws
should be made based on situations such
as that uh assuming everything is true
about this condo and one owner having
all the units does that mean the whole
state should have to abide by this
uh this law as a result
uh and additionally when someone owns
all these units it's like having a lot
of stock in a company
are we going to take away that person's
uh voting power just because we're
worried about what they're going to do
it's un-american for one thing and it's
probably unconstitutional i think if
someone has all that voting interest
what can we really do about that
should someone who owns a majority
interest be forced to
have the minority voting interest decide
everything that happens at that condo uh
it just doesn't make sense to me from a
constitutional perspective or or
one of a property rights perspective and
i'll limit my comments there thank you
we do have questions if you're willing
to take something oh absolutely
representative abel
there okay um
yes uh technology sometimes slows us
down here uh finding the right button uh
mr lennon thank you for your uh your
testimony and uh i do have a question
what kinds of protections against
conflict of interest would you feel are
appropriate for uh for condominium
associations
well certainly disclosure i think would
be the key you know if if again you know
you're talking about on a board level so
if a board member
is bidding on the plowing contract
everyone at that table five people three
people should know you know that it's uh
director jones's company so
even a disclosure law doesn't really
seem necessary because you're just
talking about a small group to the
extent that owners are voting on
something
disclosure to the to the whole makes
sense because they might not know abc
plowing is mr jones's company
um
other than that uh
to me it's up to the
the boards to inform the electorate and
it's up to the electorate to inform
themselves i think
okay uh representative herbert you have
a question
i can't see you chris i don't know
whether you're hearing me okay no
i can hear you sir thank you
for uh letting me uh ask a question i
seem to not ask questions very well
but uh
uh would you believe
that that that business model uh
should be illegal
in my opinion i mean i understand what
you're saying but uh uh how do you a
disclosure a disclosure is a good idea
to me
uh but i that to me and when they're a
majority owner
in the properties because this is not a
small
situation
as the uh representative pointed out
there are several condominium
associations that this particular
business person
has majority uh
ownership now disclosure would be good i
i think that's a good idea
but uh if in fact
uh
there is a monopoly situation exists and
uh as a result of that there
there is a uh
you know conflict of interest and and
it's quite lucrative i i just was
uh i was wondering if as as an attorney
uh what you would do
in order to protect the people who are
renting and or owning the condos
well there's you know it's a difficult
question because there's there's
certainly the the power of the vote you
can vote in a board or board members
to represent you know the minority
interest but
you know if you acquire a whole bunch of
units that gives you
certain power gives you certain
abilities
and i'm not sure we should legislate
those abilities away if you can scoop up
a whole bunch of google stock
shouldn't you have say in what that
company does otherwise what's the point
of owning the stock
so i i think you have severe
constitutional issues when you're
telling someone who owns a large portion
of something that they're not allowed to
exert some influence
um
i i just
i keep on saying it's un-american i'm
not sure there's any other way to say it
but if you own a lot of something you
have the right to control it and perhaps
people shouldn't buy there uh if if they
re you know if they don't want to cede
control to someone who who owns the
majority
okay you all said chris
yes chairman thank you very much
okay uh represent ammon has a question
keith you there
i'm here i'm sorry about that
i i got two mute buttons
just in case
uh thank you for taking my questions
thank you mr chair um my question uh
relates to
having a majority interest
in
let's say a hundred unit condo let's say
i own 60
60 units in that 100 unit
building
aren't i incentivized to
maintain that property so that
my units maintain their value because if
if the value goes down in other units
that's a comparable
uh you know that's a
real estate comp and uh i would lose
money
uh on my unit so aren't i incentivized
to
you know provide for the best interest
of the entire complex
i i certainly see it that way you have
every incentive
perhaps more than anyone else you want
to see these property values rise so
i totally agree with that and i wish i
thought of it myself
okay thank you representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i've got quite a few people who do both
plow business
in
seabrook and they do something else
if somebody is a very successful plow
business or even if they have a fleet of
trucks
plow trucks would it be
i mean
wouldn't they want to be able to buy
condos and apartments and things like
that and take advantage of the savings
that they can do you know plow business
internally that sounds like what you
believe question
well it is i mean it's throwing it out
there in case he has a
i mean
yeah i think when you're
when you're performing work for
the place you live or where you own
you want to do a good job you know
you're going to have to answer to your
your neighbors perhaps your friends
the idea is to do the best job possible
if if you're doing the work for your own
buildings you want people to slip and
fall of course you don't because as a
majority owner you have a lot at stake
financially
so i do think um
i do think that's
an incentive for the plower in this or
the roofer who whatever the contractor
is um and the other on the other hand
maybe you're going to give a better deal
because you can afford to do that so
the minor you know if we're talking
about 33 owners who aren't this majority
owner they're going to benefit from a
lower price because uh the majority
owner can afford to do so so i think
there can be situations where it's a
win-win
um you know are there bad people out
there of course they are but there are
bad contractors you're going to hire
with a board that's totally
disinterested and there's no conflict so
i i just don't think you can legislate
away everything and these situations are
so rare where there's a majority owner
in a condo so so rare
all right thank you great thank you very
much
uh so i just promoted you uh
lou
oh i don't even see where you
did you get the
i no i didn't put oh i'm sorry i didn't
forgot julia i did gary
didn't hear you over there
i'm losing track of who
but uh
huddy i'm here
okay go ahead
thank you very much i'll be very brief
because frankly dean touched on several
of the points i would have made and i
agree so i will focus primarily on just
two points
um the question came up as to whether or
not this is something that makes sense
for associations to govern for
themselves in their condominium
documents and i think the answer to that
question is yes and in fact i have seen
any number of sets of condominium
documents in which this issue is
addressed and so i think association by
association
is the way for them to handle this based
on
what they choose to put in their
documents the second point i would make
is really just putting a focus on
something that we're talking about
and that's this notion of the majority
owner so it's been said a number of
times that the majority owner gets to
vote in this contract and then because
it's their business
they are now just making all of this
money
well um again consider that the way a
condominium works for each unit that you
own
you're responsible for paying the
condominium fee
so if you're talking about someone who
owns a majority of the units in an
association they're paying the condo fee
on each of those units which means their
money is the majority of the
association's total budget at the end of
the day
and so in effect you know whether they
contract with their own company or
otherwise what the association is
spending when the association spends its
money
is mostly the money of that majority
owner um so i just want to clarify that
it's not sort of like profit in a vacuum
um to the extent that that the owner is
wearing both hats and their company is
getting paid to do the job it's mostly
their money that's paying that company
because they're paying the condo fee on
each of those units that they own
um
beyond that i i will uh in the interest
of time uh let you move on i know there
are other speakers
okay i have no more questions and uh so
uh zulu
they promoted you and you're all set
thank you representative hunt and thank
you
members for allowing me to speak on hb
466. my name is lou gargiulo i've been
involved in new hampshire condominium
associations for 35 years i purchased my
first unit in hampton in 1986.
over the years i've served in multiple
capacities as a unit owner a board
member a property manager and yes a ceo
of a large management firm based in new
hampshire that employs more than 150
employees i also served in the general
court and understand how important your
role is in enacting the best thought out
laws for the people of new hampshire
for the members not familiar with
condominiums although i think a lot of
you have become more familiar today
condominiums associations are governed
by an elected board of of directors that
board is chosen through an election
process
each condominium unit has one vote and
the board members serve for a period
dictated by the association's
condominium documents that board is
charged with ensuring the best insuring
the business of the association uh and
that they act in the best interest of
the association members
and for your information an association
member is not a tenant unfortunately
representative reed i don't think
understands that the association members
are those who own units in that
association
i am here today because i oppose this
bill for a host of reasons
it strips away the rights of a unit
owner who may or may not be a board
member from voting on contractual issues
because they provide a service in an
association in some situations an owner
may own a large group of units and this
bill will allow the minority group of
units to control an owner who owns the
majority of units it will strip away the
fundamental proposition of one unit one
vote please keep in mind that the
majority owner as said earlier pays a
majority of the expenses and this bill
they will lose the right to have their
say
on its face i believe the bill is
unconstitutional
it uh deprives individuals of
contractual rights established in the
condominium documents and it
discriminates against them because they
are a service provider and a unit owner
in addition only a select few of
providers are being targeted why not the
insurance agent the lawyer the
structural engineer or anyone else who
provides a service to the association
i can answer that question pretty
clearly this bill was introduced as an
affront to one particular individual
folks that's me
i am not a huge business i am not a huge
unit owner but i do own units at a
variety of locations i've worked hard in
my life and have built a significant
portfolio i should not be penalized and
my constitutional rights should not be
stripped away because of one
representative who has a vendetta who
does not even own a unit in that
particular property she's a tenant there
and i love tenants i can assure you i do
but they don't have a say in what goes
on it's the unit owners and in the
association that she is referencing the
unit owners have clear understanding
there is no conflict the conflict only
exists when it's not disclosed and
everyone knows about who owns a unit who
manages the property with that said i'd
open it up to any of you for any
questions thank you very much
representative abramson has a question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative gargiulo for coming in to
testify
uh you said that you own quite a few or
you have quite a few properties uh i do
you also provide uh some of the services
for those properties like plowing
no we don't provide plowing but we do
provide property management just so that
you understand the scale we manage more
than 350 associations across new england
uh i own units large numbers and about
four associations uh so
so that the information is correct for
the record
all right thank you very much
all right well thank you very much for
your testimony
uh so that is it for speakers um
senator tom sherman is in support of the
bill
and kit lord is also a member of the
public who's in support of the bill and
with that we'll close the public hearing
on house bill 466 and thank you all
okay i think we're
probably doing on scheduling here
uh
ooh
i got four minutes
nice time good work
um i i as uh someone who was uh
in in the committee last year just so
you know that language the canary
benefit language uh was lifted from
legislation that i worked on many many
years ago
which is for non-profits
and that if you are on the board of a
non-profit and you do any activity with
that non-profit
that's considered a bikinary benefit
that's where the language comes from and
there are dollar amounts listed there um
but if it's less than five dollars
all you have to do is make sure the
person's not in the room but that if it
gets over 500 or i think it's up to if
it's over 2500
um you have to print it in the newspaper
that a board member of a non-profit had
a has the beginner identification
so that's where that all that language
came from
okay
uh
so
condoms or condos
so so pam i have a question for you
um you know when you send you send these
speakers and stuff to me you don't you
don't send it to the committee members
right i'm the only one who gets these
things i send them to you and the clerk
because some i was thinking especially
when i had that one that had
233 people and it might be helpful to be
sending them to the members of the
committee too because theoretically it's
public information it normally would
have been stuck in the folder when you
have the blue sheet and the files so i
don't know
is there any been talking about making
passing this on to the committee members
also so there has been talk about that i
have not heard um the resolution of that
okay
discussion
you can put in my word i think it's a
good idea to demand it
that way
read it because then they could go read
it for themselves but yeah before the
long ones i think the idea was that
you'd have at least the totals you know
yes i've already said you wouldn't want
to read 100 names you know people would
glaze over anyway you know that you
wouldn't be able to absorb
how many were in favor and against just
by
but i think people might like to see
who's on the list too oh yeah no i
understand what you're saying i'm just
saying that that's one
innovation that that has been made
lately you know we are adapting
um just about every day here
it's it's a moving target it's great
thank you for bringing that up mr chair
i think that we would all appreciate it
it's all electronic anyway all the time
uh i would i would say yeah you have to
be uh today was a little tricky pan
because some of them did you send them
as a pdf file or some of them i didn't
come through clear the pdf ones are good
if they if they come in the other ones
they're kind of cut and paste they were
a little fuzzy um i don't know in my
printer today i thought they were all
pdfs today yeah
well i i
won't put out the
yes
i think it maybe what happened was i
just tried to print the email
and so therefore it it has it has pdfs
on it and then it has
bills that i that i can barely use
but that but yeah you know once i i was
able to get them correctly by uh going
into my pdf file and getting that
they don't always print the embedded uh
documents
okay
uh i think um representative abramson
has a question for you oh yep sir yes go
ahead max or did you still have your
hand up from last time
yeah okay
sorry no problem
okay it's 10 30 so let's open up the
public hearing on house bill 358
and i will ask representative mcwilliams
you just raise your hand
actually you don't have to i see you now
okay
i'm moving over
it's a little tricky they sort the names
by your first name
a little tricky
but i'm doing okay i think i'm doing
okay here
good morning representative mick
williams
good morning chair hunt can everyone
hear me yes we can excellent
uh for the record my name is
representative rebecca mcwilliams i
serve in merrimack 27 which is the west
side of concord
uh we've got a about six inches of snow
today
so um
i'm here to basically
introduce this bill um
for those of you who are around in 2019
uh this may look somewhat familiar
uh this has been revised from house bill
562 in 2019 it's been refined and
changed with input from members of this
committee
basically if you take a look at the bill
it's just a paragraph
it's really straightforward i encourage
you all to take a quick read of it
what the goal here is is to set a date
and from this date forward we are
removing barriers to solar installations
on condos in new hampshire
and the specific barrier that this bill
is intended to remove
is requiring a larger vote than a simple
majority in order to install solar
on a condo
so we're talking about if a new
condominium is built
say this year
after the enacting date of this
legislation so december 1st a new condo
is constructed
everyone starts moving in and there's
discussion as to whether or not solar
will be installed on this new condo uh
well it was built and opened and the
bylaws went into effect after the uh
condom the condominium statute that is
proposed here goes online
then they would need to vote 50
plus one vote a simple majority in order
to put solar on that condo
i've also included if you have an
existing condominium and the
bylaws are revised or changed and um
and so they're making a
an edit to the way that the condominium
is being run
then that also would trigger this uh
statutory date meaning that if the
bylaws were changed after the enabling
date of this legislation then it would
also fall under the 50
plus one simple majority vote in order
to install solar on that specific
condominium
and the reason this is proposed is
because
there are all kinds of differing and
varying bylaws across the state for how
and
what is the requirement in order to make
a vote to do a change to a common area
and
so instead of having an sort of
hodgepodge of well this condo
in durham requires a three-quarters vote
this condo in concord requires a
two-thirds vote
this condo in
manchester is a simple majority it
streamlines the process and makes it a
simple majority when you're voting about
installing solar
so that's really the intention is to
remove barriers as of a date certain
moving forward you would still obviously
need to have that vote and get enough
votes this is not
bullying something through the system
it's just changing the vote requirement
globally for all of new hampshire condos
so with that i'm happy to take questions
okay representative van halton has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for being with us i just
have a question about the clarity of the
language does this say that and i i've
disclosed that i am a condo owner does
this say that if i wish to put up
a system myself
i would have to get
a majority vote plus one
for my unit and then if the person next
to me wants to put one up that has to go
through the process again
the way it is written and i'm looking at
the language that you're also looking at
it says
no condominium shall require a vote of
the unit owners of greater than a simple
majority to consent to the installation
and operation of a solar photovoltaic
energy system in or on a unit so that's
the piece that you're talking about um
am i correct in assuming that you
actually have sort of detached buildings
that you would be talking about doing a
solo solar install on your own roof
well i actually now live in a detached
building my question is is basically
does each individual unit owner have to
go for a vote before the board
so that i could get a vote of yes if i
lived in a detached unit or even if i
lived in a uh in a community building
uh and then the next unit
next door to me would have to go in
other words is this just an individual
vote per unit owner
the way it's written it does appear that
it would be for the
solar photovoltaic energy system right
so what are we defining as the solar
photovoltaic energy system if you're
just proposing installing solar panels
on one rooftop
i'm not saying that that's a good use of
time or money generally solar would be
much more efficient in bulk
but if that were the proposal then
that's how it would be handled according
to this bill
um the way it's written
but i would i would kind of push back on
your question and say generally if you
have
a proposed solar project
it would be for
a rather large area because there is a
huge benefit in doing it all at once
so i'm i'm questioning where that would
actually happen that there's just one
rooftop with proposed solar and everyone
votes for that rooftop yes another
rooftop with proposed solar later
everyone votes against that other
rooftop
okay thank you very much i'm um
and i guess that's just my question do
we have to keep voting over and over or
do we have a blanket
uh statement that any kind of vote has
to be
simple majority greater than the simple
majority and doesn't have to keep going
back to the board and to the the condo
owners
it's for the energy system meaning the
project if there's one project it's one
vote if there are two projects proposed
or phased it would be two votes excuse
me so if we want to put in a solar
system say in the clubhouse
um that would be one vote simple
majority if we wanted to do that for
another
community building that we
set up an indoor tennis court
we would have to vote for that
separately am i correct
if they're being installed in two
different phases
with two different contractors
potentially then the answer is yes if
they're being installed in one phase
with one contractor it would be one
project
so this really i'm sorry may i follow
the question yes
thank you so this really has nothing to
do with the individual condo unit
it's for a much larger project am i
correct
understanding the economics of scale
i would expect that yes that is true
it's for a much larger project however
if you have individual say townhomes
with one or two units in the townhomes
and they're scattered about a campus
and we're only talking about doing solar
on the south facing rooftops in the
campus
so it's multiple projects perhaps with
just one unit owner then this would also
cover that scenario
thank you that helps a great deal
representative herbert
thank you uh thank you uh chairman hunt
uh just following on so i get i
understand what uh you have in mind with
this legislation is that
uh just by definition of the uh putting
in a solar installation
it's not likely that
say there's a 200 unit
condominium association and there's
three buildings
right and they're like three stories
and all everything is common the common
roof on every one of those
uh buildings is uh
uh
shared it's a community uh you know
community owned so it by definition
follow i i'm trying to get this straight
if
a majority vote
of the condo condominium association
would was to put in solar
that would be one vote and all three
buildings would get a solar installation
as a as an operational reality
right nobody's gonna nobody's gonna
allow
uh
in that kind of a condominium
association allow one unit to put in the
solar installation on the top of that
roof
am i am i uh you know stumbling over
myself
so you you mentioned economies of scale
you're good you got it that's a question
okay okay
thank you
yes i'm trying to understand how you
what you imagine there
so
to answer your question
there's no way in
in a business proposition that unit
number 101
puts solar on all three building
rooftops to benefit unit 101
or even just a small installation on one
rooftop to benefit itself
from a business proposition this would
be a project where
everyone decides that solar is a benefit
for the entire
all all of the condo owners it's it's a
benefit for everyone and so they decide
we're doing an array on one two or three
rooftops to benefit everyone they could
just do an array on one rooftop and
still benefit all three buildings it's
possible
but it really depends on south facing
and some other project variables about
how much sun you actually get if it
makes sense to do all three rooftops
but really the goal here is to benefit
all owners
okay thank you
thank you very much
representative mckee
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee and i'm happy to come to speak
to you today on behalf of hb 358.
um i actually partook in the hearings
last time around and a lot of the
questions that time
uh were
fixated on
the issues that condo associations were
having have having around grappling with
uh how to approach solar technology um
and i think that all of that is true
but it is also unrelated to i think the
objective of representative mcwilliams
efforts here
and so the only thing that i would add
to what she had said is that
i think what we're doing is we're
hearing i've been hearing from
constituents who've asked me for this
they've said hey you know why can't
condo owners simply uh be able to move
forward with solar projects well
if you're in a condo you're in a
different type of housing but you still
should have the option to lower your
electric bills if you want to invest in
that and if you can get the other people
who live in your neighborhood you know
your condo association to agree that
that's a good investment that you'll all
benefit from so it's really about making
the option more available to people
because the burden of two-thirds or
three-quarters is very significant in
getting people to understand
how the project could be of benefit or
even getting them
heard on a regular basis so it's really
about adaptation
um
and transition that we're basically
saying
right now it's really really hard for
somebody to get a project even if it's
viable and get it over two-thirds or
three-quarters
when really what you're trying to do is
make sure that the majority of people in
your condo association agree
with the proposal so
it's really to me it's about you know
fairness and
choice and um allowing people to option
because the option wasn't available
before and so i think we're just trying
to lower the burden
um to just make it uh majority rule
yeah
fair enough
any questions from the committee members
uh seeing that
thank you very much for your testimony
and uh gary
dario you're
you're up next
hi uh good morning again and thanks
again for some time uh i will try to be
brief
um as is often the case
i just feel in looking at this bill that
once again we're looking at an issue
that should really be governed on an
association basis there's no reason why
this can't be addressed by associations
in their own governing documents
for many it already is
for instance adding something to an
association that didn't previously exist
triggers an improvement vote and those
standards are already in place in the
documents
i would point out that the existing law
um and it has been this way for years is
that as a default standard amending the
documents requires a two-thirds vote
and again by statute if you're looking
at potentially terminating the
condominium so that the unit owners can
own the property separately or sell it
and cease to be in association with each
other
by law that requires an 80 percent vote
so the default standards that are in
place today um tend to be something more
than a simple majority um and i think
that's for good reason because when
you've got people living together um
sharing the space sharing uh the
buildings and
having agreed to live under the
governing set of documents for that
association
it's important to make sure that to the
extent there's going to be a fundamental
change that there are a significant
number of folks who are looking for it
i think that this one really is very
much like the
ham radio bill that we all spoke of
days ago last week i think that once
again you've got the interests of some
of the owners that by statue
would take an unfair advantage over the
others and would tend to do away with
what the existing condominium documents
already say you also will have the same
practical issues here meaning what
happens when holes start getting drilled
in the roof or other parts of the
building
what happens if a piece of equipment
blows off
and injures
property or injures a person
i know from personal experience having
solar on my house which by the way is an
example of me not being against the
concept of solar
in the same way that i'm not against cam
radio operators but i had solar on a
house
that i lived in and um it was definitely
the case and the company warned me of
this that the panels being as flat and
as sleek as they are
the snow at a certain point in the
winters
reaches a weight where it slides off the
panel and then it crashes to the ground
sometimes unsettlingly along the border
of the building and all of these things
are are greater problems you know when
you have people living in these
community settings
than you would in a single family home
so
i would ask the board to consider
all of that and to just again along the
lines of the ham radio bill
take note of the fact that in an
association
an individual unit owner simply doesn't
own that roof it's not their property to
install equipment on or drill holes in
and these are fundamental basics of
condominiums so i think we need to
uphold these principles again after all
people choose to live in these
condominium associations they're not
forced to do so
beyond that i'll just take a quick
moment to say that if the bill was to go
forward uh i do have some suggestions i
think it makes more sense
if it is being
proposed to deal with the association
project on an association scale
meaning that that the entire association
is involved with the solar project but
as it's worded it definitely does not
say that
at present and so at present with the
wording we have here an individual unit
owner who wanted to put solar up on the
roof for their own benefit would be able
to use this bill to say i need a lesser
vote so to the extent that this is meant
to apply to an association and not to
individual owners i think that would
need to be made clear
i also think it needs to be made clear
what the simple majority vote is of
again i'm against the idea of a simple
majority vote because generally speaking
the standards are higher both in
governing documents and in the law but
in any event it's important to define a
vote at a condominium association and
what i mean by that is are we talking
about the votes of the association as a
whole
or are we talking about the votes of
persons attending a particular meeting
on this subject matter
and i think it's always important for
the votes to be described as being of
the association as a whole
because you have a lot of communities
especially in an area like new hampshire
where
the
so-called snowbirds if you will are gone
for the winter and so attendance at the
association is low to begin with and
then even at a large association on any
given evening that a meeting is
scheduled
if you only have 10 people appear and
then six of them vote in favor of solar
now all of a sudden a solar project is
moving forward and and that may just be
a tiny fraction of the actual community
so again if it were moving forward a
recommendation would be that this vote
be described in further detail and that
it be described to apply to the voting
power of the association as a whole
not just who may participate in one
particular meeting
finally
i'm a little bit concerned about the
last part of this bill that states that
it will apply not only going forward but
to an association that amends their
governing documents
as a condominium law practitioner i can
tell you that for one reason or another
every association amends their documents
from time to time almost all of my
clients have felt the need to do so
between
and now just because of the amendments
and i'm not saying it's a bad thing
but but just the amendments that have
passed
in new hampshire
to the condominium act 356b
most of my clients have found a need to
make a change to be in compliance and so
i would urge you to consider that as
long as this bill says it also applies
to a condominium who amends their
documents that that really makes this a
bill of general applicability because at
one time or another everybody amends
their documents and then they would get
pulled into this so the
the proactive nature of the bill that
was originally described i think really
falls by the wayside
okay uh we do have a couple of questions
uh representative abramson
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um uh my concern is
about what you mentioned the majority um
are there condo associations where the
the the number of condo buildings are so
large that you have your overall condo
association for the whole property and
then also you have
you know
different groups that vote for
individual buildings
uh there are
and so that sort of creates another
level of complexity and another problem
with um putting a measure like this into
law
because it doesn't take account for all
of those nuances the way that the
governing documents of the associations
actually do and what you're describing
um is what we often refer to as like a
master and sub setup meaning that
there's a master association
and a board that makes decisions on a
property-wide basis and then smaller
segments within that community exist as
sub-associations sometimes
as you say the buildings are
individually so large that i deal with
associations where each building is a
sub-association
that is also part of the overall master
association
so yes that exists and and yes a bill
like this um would create problems in
that situation because it's not at all
clear how it would work
follow-up
for the question you may inquire
then for your proposed amendment if we
were going to go forward with this bill
and tread and and correct these problems
would you prefer that we do it break it
up building by building or the whole
association or the smallest association
unit
i think if it's to go forward um the
best measure would be to make it apply
in the broadest sense
so that it applies to an association as
a whole or that where there are multiple
associations or a master association in
a in a group of sub associations i think
that it should be handled at that
highest level
the reason being that there should be
consistency and equality and so for
instance
you could have a scenario where if
applied on a building by building basis
you may end up with
you know
discontent
in the community because you've got a
building reaping the benefits of lower
electric bills because of their solar
but other buildings don't have the solar
and then some buildings if it were
building by building vote it might pass
in one building not pass in another and
then the people who like solar that live
in a building where it didn't pass now
they resent the fact that they live in
this particular building and have these
particular neighbors
so for those reasons i think it should
apply on the broadest level possible and
again it would almost need to because
since um something like the roof where
these panels are usually placed is owned
by the association and not the
individual unit owners
it would appear that it is most
appropriate for the decision to be made
at the highest level because that is
really who sort of
controls for ownership purpose the
property in question which again is most
likely the roof
great uh representative burrows
yes thank you for taking my question um
if this were um to be implemented on the
um the the broadest possible level as
you're saying my concern or actually say
are you concerned that because of the
cost of solar if it was 50 plus one um
that's that could be a huge expense for
individual property owners so does that
concern you that it might be the
just a small majority there
uh absolutely in fact to be clear my my
position in general is against this bill
um not because again not because i'm
against solar but because i don't think
it works well this type of measure in a
condominium association context
um but certainly
there is an issue involved with
the fact that any number of people which
is usually why the voting standards are
set high but there's always a concern
when a number of people
might pass a vote that then has an
impact on everyone else in the community
especially uh financial impact so yes at
any level
there is concern there because i think
that
again
the associations primarily should be
able to govern themselves and uh unit
owners should be making a choice about
where they want to live and so again
like like the ham radio folks it becomes
a matter of choosing to live in a place
where um you know it's not restrictive
against something that you feel is
important for you in your life
thank you
okay
christina i assume you got your
questions answered okay yeah i i need to
ask my question there you go perfect
okay
uh i guess we're all set thank you very
much
and last but not least is uh dean
lennon
i'm not sure i can add anything that
gary didn't say he did a tremendous job
so thank you very much okay perfect even
better okay
um so having oh i do have an attendees
got a hand up
so uh represent mcmillions you would
like to
uh
put you back i guess and and
have you have the final say
there you go go ahead
thank you chair uh hunt
um i i just wanted to take an
opportunity to rebut a little bit of the
comments that were previously stated by
mr d'addario um first of all the
case-by-case basis which
sounds like his preference is that
condos address this issue on a
case-by-case basis
understanding that the default rule in
new hampshire is that you need a
two-thirds vote by the
entire association as a whole
in order to change your bylaws
you would need a two-thirds vote to
change the bylaws to allow a fifty
percent plus one vote to put solar on
each individual condo across the state
and i would argue that that's incredibly
unwieldy and highly unlikely to happen
so it would in effect
cause this not to happen because you're
not going to see all those two-thirds
votes and you're not going to see the
individual initiative from each of the
condos across the state
also
i think that
there really is no unfair advantage to
installing solar with a majority vote
the advantage would be decreased
electric bills for everyone
so i'm not seeing this as anything other
than another construction project that's
being undertaken in common area and
decided upon
by the majority of the voters
for how to spend the money that the
association has
to do a construction project and
obviously those of you who are familiar
with living in condos know that
expenses come up construction projects
happen uh you need all kinds of
maintenance repairs a new roof
new siding
addressing issues um also when we talk
about construction there seemed to be
some concern about drilling holes in the
roof or equipment blowing off
i would argue that in this day and age
in 2021 we've gotten really good at
installing solar
so it's not necessarily the case that
there will be holes drilled in the roof
or equipment blowing off this could be
happening in a fields this could be
happening on a flat surface
um it could be uh mounted with sandbags
rather than
drilled so i just want to be clear that
we've gotten really good at solar as an
industry um in the last 30 years
in addition i i am open to doing an
amendment to clarify about having the
vote being by the whole association for
the same reasons outlined by mr dadario
i think it makes sense to be very clear
that this is about everyone voting
about whether or not a solar project
would happen it's a construction project
um
and then uh finally
the uh the intention of benefiting one
owner i would be okay with um a little
tweak in the language to to just make
sure that we're benefiting obviously the
condo owners as a whole so
that's a brief response thank you
uh okay so now it's 10 59 we're almost
in i said you're gonna be the last
speaker and then i have three hands pop
up so i can i will take the questions
but all i can ask you the three of you
and that's you in particular chris keep
make the ques question a yes or no
answer so that we can get on to the next
hearing so jane you are first
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh my question is um so if
an association
member owns several units
and he or she does not want solar or
because uh he or she has um stock or
investment in a different energy source
is that not a conflict
that's a would you believe
okay that's an interesting question but
that's a would you believe question all
right
thank you what'd you believe
okay chris
you're gonna it's gonna be easy right
chris
uh
yes sir uh thank you chairman
so um just so as i've got this clear
only association uh members who own
their condos
are involved in this vote is that
correct
in other words if there's 50 units that
are rented
the people that are renting
are going to not be able to vote
but they're going to i would i would as
an association member
want them to also help pay for this unit
so i'm just i want to make that clear
and and uh and maybe maybe recommend to
the gentleman that was
uh the business owner with majority rule
he probably should get in the solar
business
so it is unit unit owners it's just unit
owners it says unit owners are voting
yep
okay and max last but not least
a question on this hypothetical
amendment um
does this
i guess the problem i run into if you're
going to go for the whole property
instead of just the building are you
what happens if the property becomes
bifurcated or subdivided later or the
association subdivides later does this
you know if we're going to handle this
in law and this is going to handle all
cases going forward how do we address
all of the contingencies that come up
that
that we have a hard time dealing with
now what happens if
you know two condo adjacent condo
associations merge
you know how do we handle those kinds of
situations in
law so um i i just want to say this is a
construction improvement
so we would address this just like
putting up a new clubhouse
if the if the units were split out into
two different owners ownership and
compensation would be addressed the same
way as if you had built a new clubhouse
or vice versa if you added on and
purchased more units that belong to a
neighboring condo and there was
say a bond or a loan or some long-term
financial instrument related to the
clubhouse that would be dealt with as
part of the purchase and integration of
those two different entities
great we thank you very much and uh well
with this i will close the public
hearing
on
house bill 358
and so the next
one we have
is 336
and
representative gordon there you are
all right ned i'm promoting you up
okay
and you're good to go chris ned excuse
me
you have to unmute yourself
please
morning mr chair members of the
committee
good morning
good morning i am ned gordon i represent
grafton county district 9. but i'm not
appearing here today necessarily as a
representative i'm appearing as a
member of the condominium oversight
committee
which is a statutory committee
and i come as the primary sponsor of
house bill 336
this is the same bill which the house
commerce committee heard in the last
session as house bill 308
it creates or establishes a condominium
dispute resolution board
the uh
just to uh just to begin the
the the purpose of the bill
is to allow homeowners a remedy
other than going to the superior court
currently if condominium unit owners
have a complaint with the association
and that complaint may involve
the fact that the board is not complying
with the declaration or bylaws or other
condominium documents
or
it may be a complaint with regard to
wrongful voting procedures or it could
be a complaint with regard to uses of
the property
their
only remedy other than complaining to
the board itself
is to go to the superior court
and the
oversight committee condominium
oversight committee has heard repeated
concerns expressed by unit owners
that that process is
expensive that process
is intimidating
and it's a formal process it's a formal
process and that the
rules of evidence are required and
really the only way
to go through that process you really
need to have an attorney in order to do
that and because it is an intimidating
process it discourages many homeowners
from going forward
and with with their complaints or their
concerns
so they're looking for a method of
addressing those concerns
without having to go through the formal
process
what has been developed
in the legislation is a dispute
resolution board it would consist of
nine members
they would be appointed
there would be members of the house of
representatives there would be members
appointed by the governor
but nine members
some involved
potentially in the condominium industry
but there would be unit owners involved
there would be board members involved
there would be
members of the board
which would have
an interest that would be a person who
would be appointed by the bar
association
and
this board is designed after
the
the board which is currently in effect
with regard to manufactured housing
and that board has been successful
in dealing with complaints with
manufactured housing complaints
without having to have
people who
in many cases just simply do not have
the means to go to court to be able to
provide them with a remedy for their
concerns
the
the uh
uh
the legal effect of decisions uh it does
not deprive
anyone from going to court what would
happen is the dispute resolution board
would make a determination would make a
determination with regard to complaints
and
and if and then if either party the unit
owner or the association were unhappy
with the outcome they could in fact go
to court and have it resolved in court
but
if uh it's not appealed to court if
either party wants to go to court it
will become
a binding resolution to the complaint
and
i think that that is a fair uh outcome
and a good way of resolving the
complaints in a fair and equitable
manner and in an economical manner
uh
like most people i don't necessarily
want to see more regulations or more
levels of bureaucracy
uh but this is a way of providing people
with a remedy without having to go
through the formal process of going to
obtain that remedy
and
i would
entertain any questions that people may
have
uh great thank you we do have some
questions representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i do have a i actually like the idea of
the bill
i do have a concern that
the members are
a lot of them are just members of the
general court who under our constitution
can't be compensated
um other than the hundred dollar a year
honorarium um it looks like
i i guess i guess i'm guessing that
there would be a lot of disputes that
there are quite a few of these cases
that go to court
um i'm wondering why
this
you know wouldn't go maybe to the
housing board
or
some other organization
to just look at the facts of the case
and decide the case based on the facts
i think the design of the board
was created with the purpose of having
people who generally were familiar with
the
industry and you'll see that most people
are there's one member who's just simply
a lawyer
one member appointed by the bar
association which i think always having
some legal expertise
added is a good idea
with regard to the legislative members
i guess i could let you decide whether
you think that's in the interest but
frankly i think having the legislature
involved is not a bad idea
i'm not sure that
i'm concerned about their compensation
but that's another whole issue
okay
uh next up is representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
we have lost our institutional memory
with kermit
williams
that because this bill has come up so
many times
would you be able to
refresh
our memories and inform others that
we're not in on these the last
few sessions
of why we haven't been able to move
forward with this i think a lot of
people understand the need for it
but it hasn't passed and it's very
complicated i know that you have
amended it a number of times
can you help us
well yes and uh and and frankly i'm
bringing the bill forward because kermit
wasn't re-elected and he he did bring
this bill forward and he was the prime
sponsor last year
the
this bill
is uh different than the bill
this is the same bill as last year but
the bill that was offered last year
was uh substantially amended
to
make it more streamlined and to make it
apply only for complaints that were made
by
unit owners so
it's unit owners complaints only
it also did some other things that
this particular bill makes it so it's
non-binding so if in fact there is a
decision that's made either party the
association
whichever can bring their complaint
forward to the superior court if they
wish to do so
um
but it's it's been redesigned uh as of
last year last year's bill was
redesigned to make it more efficient
more practical
um
less bureaucratic and so i think that's
one of the reasons why the bill perhaps
had more success last year than it had
in the past and and should have more
success this year
thanks very much
okay uh represented him
thank you very much mr chairman
um i have i have a question and and uh
and then a follow-up if i can
um does this apply to
cooperatives
[Music]
a group of folks that get together
and
form a cooperative on the land in common
but on their home
does this apply to them also
it does not apply to cooperatives
homeowners associations
or to
timeshare
and
i can tell you that our committee
frequently hears issues with regard to
or i soon say issues they hear
complaints with regard to homeowners
associations and cooperatives and
i think perhaps legislation needs to be
put in place with regard to that as well
but this has this bill has nothing to do
with cooperatives homeowners association
or timeshare
follow-up please the question you may
inquire yes um
i was uh i was hoping the answer was
that it did apply to cooperatives
because most of the things i hear of
um are
are related to to co-ops but it's the
same exact um
type of um community living
uh neighbors neighborly disputes come up
i'm sure it's the same in condominiums
as what i hear in cooperatives that
you're living in close quarters and
neighbors get on each other's nerves
and it would be good uh to have a place
to go
to um
to
perhaps resolve their dispute it could
be between neighbor to neighbor or or
one um
one person in the um condominium
complex that's unhappy with the board or
unhappy with the owner of the
property and so it's a good place to go
without having to run to court to try to
be heard
both parties are telling this story
and come up with something that seems to
be a reasonable uh compromise
would you believe that that i think that
that this would be a good idea and if we
could only expand it to co-ops and
associations and others that also would
be a good thing
representative ham i actually put in an
lsr to create uh
some regulation with regard to
homeowners associations and co-ops but
i didn't uh bring it forward this year
because of the covet year and the
complexity of the issue
and thought that perhaps bringing it
forward in the next year would be better
for everyone
thank you
representative van halen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative i actually also agree uh
that some kind of regulation is needed
and i'm glad that this once again
parallels the manufactured housing
legislation because
there are things that are tried and true
i do have some non-specific questions
about some of the language and i'd like
to see some of the language tightened up
i'm just looking at at um
there's a section that talks about the
chairperson for the board shall be
chosen from blah blah blah but shall
serve at the pleasure of the members of
the board i'm not sure what that means
shall serve at the pleasure of the
members of the board um there's another
other sections too and i don't mean to
diminish at all the work that went into
this but i think if we're going to do
something of this sort and it's
all-encompassing it's a very large piece
of legislation that it needs to be done
appropriately i'm looking at another um
out-of-context
sentence that says i may exclude
evidence which in the opinion of the
board is immaterial irrelevant or unduly
repetitious again these are issues that
um and i i did i did begin this morning
by stating that i am an owner of a condo
and i live in a condo association and by
and large the questions and concerns
that i have been raised for me since the
advent of covid
um have been these little itty itchy
glitchy kinds of things people have gone
back to
356b to attempt to answer their
questions and reading legislation can be
formidable i find it for medical as well
so
my question is simply this would you be
open to going back to tightening some of
this language by amendment in order to
be sure that we close some of the
possible loopholes that um that can't
arise because as the previous speaker
said
neighboring neighbor can sometimes get
very contentious
we had issues about whether the tennis
court should be closed because it's
coveted or not
and that was contentious between the
tennis players and those who said you
know kovit is is threatening my
livelihood and i don't care about tennis
again i'm sorry for the length of that
question uh just to paraphrase and to
come to the heart of it would you be
open to going through some of the
language to make sure that it's a bit
tighter as much as possible
i i'd be
obviously i'd be more than happy to do
an amendment to make any improvement in
the legislation that was needed i
i need if i'm going to do that i need to
understand what the loopholes are i
guess and
and
to do that i know we have gone through
the legislation i can't tell you how
many times we've gone through the
legislation to try to tighten it up as
much as we can so
again i'd be more than happy to amend
something if i
if i
think there's a problem
uh thank you um just a quick follow-up
i'm a teacher of english and so maybe i
get a little hung up on language
sometimes but i do think that legalities
need to be carefully worded so thank you
very much and i'll be looking at the
legislation to see if i can be
supportive of that idea
thank you
okay
uh seeing none no no more hands because
i know connie wants to put her hand down
uh so
uh thank you very much uh thank you mr
chair
and uh and uh
i will now call on will infantine
who is also signed up to speak uh
against the bill
thank you mr chairman i will be
extremely brief because i know you're
busy it seems like i have condos coming
out my ears all the time it's part of my
life my company insurers have 300
different condo associations in new
hampshire and massachusetts i've served
on four boards before
and i own a condo so i've seen the good
the bad and the ugly uh more often than
not though it's all does work itself out
uh between boards changing of boards
people uh
deciding that um
to resolve an issue um professionally
versus legally
i don't think the government should be
involved uh with disputes can you
imagine if we had a dispute resolution
board for small claims court we had a
few representatives on them uh first of
all i don't think representatives should
be adjudicating things that kind of a
cross between the legislative and
judicial branches there in my opinion um
this has been reviewed a number of times
while it
it's a
laudable idea
i i don't think it it would be
successful i also just don't think the
numbers make make any sense
um
what you would charge someone to come in
and have a dispute versus the cost of
the attorneys and the other things so in
essence the government would probably be
paying
more than it receives
for this service and i'm just not sure
that's the goal of government thank you
mr chairman
thank you for being a model of brevity
uh any questions from committee members
uh seeing seeing uh oh representative
abramson has a question
sorry mr chair i was cleaning my uh
keyboard and i had to turn it off it's a
bluetooth keyboard um
same question thank you representative
infantine um for taking my question uh
same question as before do you see any
reason why you know we already have this
housing appeals board with three
salaried members is there any reason why
disputes couldn't be taken there before
they go on to superior court
you know i don't know enough about what
that board does to see whether it fits
within um
what how they what they were established
to do
um so i can't i'm sorry i can't answer
that because i just don't know enough
about what that board does
all right thank you and for members
that's under rsa 679 that's uh took
effect july of last year
uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um
i was just wondering uh representative
infantine if you have any idea how many
condo bills we get regarding disputes
um this committee deals with this year
after year after year and
i wondered if you realize that
this dispute resolution board was really
one of the aims has been to try to keep
the legislature out of all of these
disputes
so that they have a place to go just
like the manufactured housing does
uh representative bartlett i am aware i
do watch these year and year out and i
was very pleased four or five years ago
when i think it was representative
almighty and current uh and i'm sorry i
can't remember
his last name
the whole thing really did a great job
in and revising the entire uh
condominium off and then it was amazing
to me that the following year
three or four more bills it does seem um
like there are a lot of these issues and
disputes but when you have people living
in the community and certain rules
you're always going to have these things
um
so yes i do you know you see all of
these things but there are other
mechanisms in place auto dealers have
their own dispute resolution with with
um customers and the attorneys have
something as well
uh
whether it's an individual outside group
that would want to be involved with this
i think that makes more sense than
having it uh involved with the
government
now follow up here's a question main
choir thank you so um
well
since you brought it up
i'd like you to have a to come up with a
suggestion
of how you think the thousands and
thousands of condominium unit owners
that do have problems
could
um
resolve these problems other than a
resolution just
dispute resolution board
would you believe
would i believe i do believe no i'm
asking him if he's got another idea
i mean we spent hours and i mean years
on this
i believe uh uh attorney general had
some ideas a few years ago of an
alternative
um
outside of government um and i just
don't recall that and i see that he's
watching maybe he can answer that
question um but you're right i mean
there are disputes that need to be
resolved and many of them are taken care
of
uh but i've seen them all i've seen
really serious ones and i've seen
ridiculously frivolous ones and
and um
there should be a better mechanism um
outside of government but i i don't want
to keep repeating myself
great uh representative abramson do you
have another question
sorry about that that's my keyboard
again okay
all right uh
thank you very much uh well
and uh
we'll have uh gary daddario to
speak in opposition to the bill
hi good morning again and thank you
again for the time
um
i guess i'll start by saying that i
agree with comments made by
representative infantine
especially with respect to the fact that
this will
certainly at the end of the day impose
some measure of cost for the state
that i'm not sure is is warranted
i guess before i get into the bill i'll
start with the question that was
recently asked about what the
alternatives are
and i would say again
that as a condominium practitioner i see
these things addressed within the
association's governing documents and so
as a for instance
there's always a provision by which a
number of unit owners can command a
special meeting to be had by an
association there are also provisions in
individual condominium documents that
allow unit owners to have a hearing
internally before their own board
at the condominium association relative
to
an alleged violation or an issue so
those are are some other avenues uh to
the extent that there would be a 250
dollar filing fee here uh i would note
that that would cover
at a minimum a consultation for a unit
owner to have with an attorney who may
be able to explain to them you know once
they hear
the problem or complaint at issue
either how to go about it or be able to
explain to them that it is or or isn't
something that can be addressed by an
individual unit owner uh somehow
it looks nice
rich
oh excuse me
with respect to the particulars of the
bill um and i guess we're at a good
point of transition for this
um
it states now it reads very much as a
one-way street meaning that unit owner
complaints would be accepted by this
board and
the language here indicates that there
would be complaints
against the board meaning that the
association board had done something
wrong so
two pieces we see
lacking here one would be for an
association
to be able to seek some assistance from
this board if this board were to exist
to deal with a unit owner
who is violating the rules
the other problem
perhaps a more significant problem
because it's been mentioned several
times that there are a lot of unit owner
to unit owner disputes because when
people live you know this close to each
other they might have disagreements and
issues
this language about a unit owner
complaining that the board is doing
things wrong means that this board uh in
the current form of this bill
would also not be hearing complaints
from one unit owner to another and so i
think if this board we're going to exist
at all it probably makes sense for it to
exist to service
whatever types of issues people are
trying to address and not just the
singular focus of a unit owner doesn't
like what the board is doing
another issue that i i see here is that
the language provides for a review to be
done of the complaint
on an initial basis and for
determination to be made about whether
or not the complaint has merit enough to
go forward
now in in concept i love that idea i
think it makes perfect sense any
complaint should be reviewed at the
outset to see what kind of merit is
there about where something should go
the problem i have and it may very well
get to due process concerns for an
association board
is that that decision gets made
the association has an opportunity to
file anything with this board
now the problem there becomes that i
would propose to you that if you look at
a complaint in a vacuum
it will almost always have an air of
legitimacy about it in other words a
unit owner might say i was at the annual
meeting
i tried to vote it's the most important
thing we do as unit owners and they
wouldn't accept my ballot and so my vote
didn't
and in a vacuum that complaint will
always look very legitimate but if the
association only had a moment or only
had the ability to to hand in a written
statement of some kind about this case
they might educate the board to the fact
that at this association the governing
documents and this is real and it's not
uncommon require unit owners to be in
good standing
in order to cast their vote and maybe
this unit owner hasn't paid a condo fee
in a year
and so by their own documents definition
they're not in good standing and that's
why their ballot didn't come in
my point is only that uh to the extent
and that's how the language here is at
present to the extent the board decides
whether or not a complaint has merit
based only on the complaint it's going
to be hard for those decisions to not
all come out one way because in a vacuum
the complaints always look like there's
something there and really you need at
least just a taste of information from
the other side
in order to be able to really weigh the
situation and see whether or not there's
a legitimate dispute
so that's an issue i have as well with
the particular wording
in in terms of the process here it's
been noted that the parties would not be
denied access to court because they
could appeal these decisions and get
into court but i would note that it also
says in the bill that this board would
not be bound by the rules of evidence
and it says in the bill that if it is
not appealed
the decision of this board would then go
to superior court where it would be
entered in the nature of a judgment of a
superior court case
and so oddly enough from a legal
perspective you would have a dispute
resolution board who's not bound by the
rules of evidence that makes a decision
that unless it's appealed
ends up being endorsed as if it was a
decision of the superior court where the
rules of evidence would have applied
and so procedurally i i think that
there's a problem there
as well
and i know others are are waiting to
speak so i think at this point i'll
limit my comments to that
thank you
uh we do have a couple of questions uh
representative bartlett you inquire
um
would you believe though that
the 250
fee
is one trying to get rid of frivolous
complaints because somebody has to think
about whether they want to spend 250 to
go before this dispute resolution board
but also
um
it's not that even if they decide to do
that
and and pay the 250
fee
they're not giving up any rights
this
i think
i mean don't you think that this kind of
board
could take care of
many of the smaller issues
um
that come before these condominium
boards
um
i would say i agree with both of those
points i think that certainly a filing
fee
and something in the nature of 250
dollars will be uh you know a bit of an
impediment
to some who would make a frivolous claim
i would agree with that i would also
agree that i'm sure that this board if
it existed um would be performing some
function
um but again i i think that i see this
type of language in a lot of association
documents where they can have their own
special meetings in their own hearings
i also think that that 250 dollars
most unit owners
don't because it isn't part of the real
estate closing process they don't
necessarily know what they've purchased
when they purchase a condominium unit
and so as a for instance i get a lot of
calls from union owners who have
received a violation letter and their
new unit owners and what they tell me is
you and your rules
need to get lost because i'm not
anybody's tenant i pay my mortgage i own
my unit
and so they don't even realize that even
though they own the unit there are
restrictions that they're required to
comply with because they're part of a
condominium community
and so again to the extent that someone
were going to spend 250 dollars i think
a consultation with an attorney might
help them a lot because someone might be
able to explain to them whether or not
there really is an issue there to pursue
but your point i also think that if this
board were going to
address a lot of the concerns out there
it would need to be the case that
associations could apply to it too to
deal with a unit owner committing
violations or that when you have these
neighbor to neighbor disputes
that they be able to go to this board
right now it really just deals and i'm
not sure why but it really just deals
with this singular notion of a unit
owner wants to complain that their board
isn't doing it right
and
it seems that to the extent that state
resources were being expended on this
board
that it should have a broader function
than that
great uh representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the same question do you see any
problem with sending these cases to that
the housing board of appeals under rsa
679 couldn't we just replace this entire
board with uh one that's already
existing
um unfortunately if i'm going to be
honest i would have to give the same
answer that representative infantine
gave um
i don't know enough about that other
board but my wheelhouse is strictly with
condominium associations um and so i
just i'm not familiar enough with that
other board to say whether or not
they would be a good source
for these disputes to to land with
fair enough
i would interject and say that the
boards are designed to address the issue
so the manufactured housing board is
more the expertise on it is about
manufactured housing not necessarily
condos
so the condo board is the theory is that
the people are on there are people who
are
aware of the issues that are going on in
condos not manufactured housing
okay thank you very much gary and
last dean lennon
hello thank you representative hunt um
i'm going to be brief and i certainly
echo what what gary has just said
i think this is a bill whose heart is in
the right place but uh in spite of the
250 dollar filing fee i think uh this is
going to result in associations having
to uh expend a lot and legal fees
defending themselves in these cases of
course they're not required to hire
counsel but when you're talking about a
decision that will essentially be a
judgment against them if they don't
appeal it you better get it right the
first time um so when owners have
issues that perhaps are frivolous
perhaps are a misunderstanding
to expend
a thousand or two thousand dollars to
defend yourself is is awfully onerous um
superior court is not the the only
option for owners they can file a in in
district court or circuit court uh they
can file in small claims court within
circuit court and that's very cheap uh
and
relatively fast
um so i'm opposed to the bill on that
basis that it's going to cause
associations to spend a lot of money uh
in addition to everything set forth uh
by gary previously thank you very
much okay any questions representative
abel
rich
oh you took your head okay oh he's
waving off okay okay okay any other
questions from anybody
uh
seeing none um
like to wrap up uh so yes representative
gordon you can speak
i i don't want to i don't necessarily
need to wrap up and and i appreciate all
of the testimony we've heard here today
but i did want to point out i i was a
circuit court judge who cannot bring
these types of cases to
the district court and small claims are
money claims only and
the district court does not have any
equity powers to deal with issues with
regard to condominiums i just wanted to
point that out correct it goes to
superior court
okay
thank you for pointing that out i should
have done that
um
and
i guess no we have nobody else no other
hands up all right so we'll uh end this
the public hearing uh on
uh house bill 336
and
that's it for this morning
well we okay
um all right so uh just for the members
so it
uh
we'll reconvene uh at 1 15 and which
would like to take up those two early
bills so we can get them on sent them on
and uh for the session in later this
month
other than that uh everyone have a good
lunch
representative hunt yes i have i have a
question about um
uh testimony uh in another uh committee
how how do i sign in to another
committee is that the zoom is that the
webinar address if i want to
um or actually not testify but just um
sign the uh blue sheet how do i do that
well you you go on to the uh
house representative's web page
okay and there's a square down there
that
walks you through it
okay i'll do that during lunch thanks
yep no problem
all right so we'll all see you at 1 15.
uh mr chair
yep i guess maybe it's a little late did
we have a caucus uh before taking up 6
10 and 76 republican caucus why don't
you give me a call
okay just call you have my landline uh
i'm pretty sure i do eight nine eight
nine nine six thousand
yeah i've got that okay just give me a
call
you missed our caucus yesterday
okay
you
foreign
all right
okay
foreign
um
hello everyone hope everybody had a nice
lunch
gone i went cross-country skiing at
cool i'm jealous
i made lunch for my daughters and i blt
sandwiches and random store and got them
some chips
that's
cool yeah the snow is nice
how much snow did you get up there joyce
oh i'd say four inches maybe
but it's a very nice quality
yeah we've got like 14 down here i know
you guys get all the luck yeah we wish
between the two of you here in laconia
you guys usually get a lot more than we
do
not this year nah
well
eight times joyce cross-country skiing
i've been i've been out eight times
already
well i like to do it every day with the
dogs but i can't
it hasn't been
possible this year
cover you know four is a little tight i
need like five i don't know
how much did you get john
so uh
it looks like a foot and
you know what that's what they reported
in the uh mu
but and we had we had that five inches
just a couple of day you know a week
before so
yeah definitely got a good base and good
stuff so i'm expecting to do a lot of
skiing
in a couple of days
i went to the quilt store and got some
um more fabric
you know you've had your got your
vaccine so you're more willing to get
out of the house
i did i got my second vaccine
appointment this morning after trying
all day yesterday at different times so
what what's their date not till april
first which will be nine weeks out
amazing i get my way too far so
hopefully the state gets us together and
gets us in time
i get my second one on monday
wow
yeah
i want to apologize to the committee for
my inadvertent remark when i was unmuted
i i have i have a new laptop computer
and
uh i've i've discovered that the mouse
when i if i'm moving it to someplace
else and it goes over the mute or unmute
it changes it without my clicking so
um
got a mind i didn't mean that i was
complimenting my wife on her on her
haircut and uh
and uh so i i i'm sorry the whole world
saw it or will see it
i thought that was sweet
yeah thank you thank you
thank you at least i didn't say
something uh something i'm really would
really be sorry about something and it
really was your wife right yes it was
okay
my wife showed up and i don't know if
you guys heard me because i turned
around and says you know this is good
right she handed me that she did get her
lice her nursing license renewed
ah cool
whether that wasn't going to happen so
but i did say you know you know this is
good
i don't know whether you guys picked it
up when i did it but i i realized before
after i did it i did not turn off my
microphone when i was well you're
unmicked all the time john i am i i i
the only time i mic up is when i i hear
out like garbage man and other things
i'll i'll i'll hit the mute button but
to me turning that thing on and off
would be you know it's like it's like
the speaker you know how this figure
always seems to forget to turn the click
the switch on and
i understand the importance of turning
your mic off you want to hear people
hear what your hands say but i feel like
i'm
i'm here on the radio post here so
i have two very large shepherds that get
the wind
so i keep mine off for that
or if my daughters decide to end on the
stairs in an argument for something
i have two black labs and they are out
of the house because they will bark at
any moment for anything
yeah
especially i reloaded the bird feeder
and and the birds are going crazy and
the dogs are
really enjoying the entertainment
yeah i've got one shepherd who likes to
talk to me
if i don't pay attention to him right
away and it's
and he'll do that for 20 minutes while i
try to ignore him and make him go away
so
and i have one puppy that is barking at
everything and they're painting the
common areas
so but right now she's being good
all right so i count 16 people
which is a quorum but that means we're
missing people
all right mr chairman can you hear me
over here
and
oh there's somebody in the room oh jason
there you go
i see you now hey jason
all right it's good and then keith good
so now let me count again one two three
four five six seven eight
ten
12 13 14
15 16
17.
okay he turned his camera on good
so jeff on the rules
jeffrey you have to turn your camera on
for exacting okay
i have a question for the chair if you
have a second yep this is our first uh
our first vote yep first one i'm
recording
so would you like to go first or less i
know there's a difference of opinion on
that
um so
i'll i'm fine with going last
okay that's fine um in the old days i
didn't have to vote at all unless to
make her break a tie
and that was i was uh
i was actually confident
so
and then recording the vote uh the form
that the clerk gave me just has like the
the total has the motion first and
second and the vote total
should i be recording uh votes on the
roll call sheet so they didn't give you
a sheet with the names and then you
you'd write check what they say yay or
nay next to the name or i don't have
something like that i have i have the
list of names for
attendance that's the only thing close i
have right so pam was he does he
supposed to have another type of cheat
for executive sessions
yeah he should have a roll call sheet i
know the
question taking care of the paperwork
ah let me look again i saved what he
sent
i have something called exec session
form
okay that works for me but it doesn't
have names on it just has the motions
and the vote totals
that's that's what paul sent out there's
no like in page two
no i i'm looking now
i can make up my own if you want we can
figure it out later
what do you want to do
um i can cut i can email paul if you
like
okay
all right well i'd like to move forward
with team ahead so make your make your
own sheet
you have the attention just use an
attendant cheat for for today and then
hopefully we'll get this problem
so i'm looking back at his original
email let me just oh wait i found it
false one
[Music]
all right
okay great uh so the chair rules that we
have a quorum
uh the first bill we want to take up is
um
house bill
this is relative to certain licensing
and reporting functions to be conducted
through the nationwide
licensing system and registry and
relative background investigation of
trust officers to certain filing fees
assessments interest rates and the
transmission of consumer complaints by
the banking department
representative hunt moves and seconded
by representative patosik
ought to pass
any discussion on the motion of us to
pass
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
just give me one sec to catch up here
i'll get faster as this
as we go
for two seconds second
yep
and it's the motion is all to pass
correct
all right uh call the roll
okay uh voice chairman patusek yes
representative jason osborne
yes
clerk votes yes keith hammond
representative max abramson
representative abramson
representative bonnie
yes
representative joseph de palma
representative jeffrey greeson
yes
representative don johnson
representative paul terry
yes
representative christy bartlett
representative bartlett yes oh
you just just muted yourself there you
go i'm sorry yes yes
representative richard abell
yes
representative christopher herbert yes
representative
connie van gaalton
nice job yes
representative christina fargo
yes
representative joyce weston
representative gene bellew
yes
representative anita burroughs yes
representative
chris mcallier yes
and max i saw you pop on representative
abramson
yep i'm here
and lastly the chair representative john
hunt yes
okay that's unanimous
okay so well that was a little tight one
there max in terms of being here when
the question was put but we'll we'll let
it go this time
but let's make sure we all tune in i
guess all right uh next
so um all those in favor placing that
bill as hospital 610 on the consent
calendar please say aye
aye
no suppose
okay those are on the consent calendar
is that 1900
that's right
thanks
did you did you call your name
i did yeah okay i'm uh
i'm third on the list and so that i'm
just going by list order so right right
okay
but make sure you say your name loud
enough so everybody can hear it i guess
okay we'll do it
okay house bill 76 prohibiting paper
billing fees
representative terry seconded by
representative patusik moves in
expedient the legislate
and representative terry is recognized
to speak to his motion
thank you mr chair uh
to be succinct is uh as possible i'm
going to uh read the following number
one of four
the bill would transfer what is
effectively a user fee to all who engage
for services with the biller that is the
provider
the sponsor has not demonstrated either
the range of adverse impact in dollars
upon paper billers
or the class of bill payers as a whole
if the bill were to be enacted into law
this is highly problematic for a
thorough consideration of the bill's
ramifications
accordingly any thought of a recommended
to pass action would be exceedingly
premature
and fraught with many unanswered
essential questions two
the bill specifically exempts
governmental agencies without providing
a rationale or statement of necessity
for doing so
exempting large governmental agencies
while adversely impacting a whole range
of much smaller providers directly or
through their customers who pay
electronically is particularly and
disturbingly nettlesome to say the least
three
the bill's sponsors have not provided
measurable and meaningful data to
demonstrate the number of customers who
have failed in their efforts to appeal
to the providers for a hardship
exemption or the types and degrees of
the difficulty encountered by customers
who have been unable to locate and
secure the services of an alternate
provider who either does not surcharge
for paper billing or whose fees are less
than the existing provider and number
four
the bill's fine for a first offense is
up to five hundred dollars this seems
rather large but more problematically
first offense is not defined as the
first billy or all those as effectively
as a class in a first billing period
brought under scrutiny
i'll stop there
okay uh representative bartlett has her
hand up
yes um i have to say that
this is catching us a little bit by
surprise
i thought that
there was really quite a lot of
testimony um at the public hearing and
that this is affecting people
um there it
i i agree that it's not ready to go the
way it is right now but i do think that
we could
uh retain it
and um
work on it
for next year
okay
uh
obviously
in terms of the the motion is that there
was a feeling that that that this bill
was is
there's too many uh ends to it to
whether it was going to get resolved
representative
vin
houghton
i mute
oh she jumped around on me i can't even
see you
i think i'm all set now am i
yep oh there you are okay i apologize
um i do agree that there are definitely
problems with this um with this bill
however i do see a constituency that has
this need that
um the older people those people without
access to computers and i would hope
also that we would take down um the itl
motion by vote and go to a retained
motion
okay
uh representative abramson has his hand
up next
oh i'm not on mute all right um so
although i agree with the sentiment of
representative bartlett and van hooten
um that
there is an issue here that needs to be
dealt with
the problems that i saw with the bill
are
are structural meaning that as i said
asked during the hearing
that this doesn't protect new hampshire
consumers
it punishes companies that move to new
hampshire and it created a second
structural problem which would also not
be solvable with making changes to this
bill which is
um
at no point
to make it clear if somebody offers a
discount for online building billing
even if it's a dollar or two or five
dollars um to do things more efficiently
would they be fined how many times would
they be fined what would be counted as a
second offense and so on and so forth so
um i don't think that retaining the bill
and trying to fix this bill would fix
the problem i think that
uh if it's even possible to fix this
problem for example out of state
companies
doing this it cert it certainly wouldn't
be fixed by retaining the bill and try
to make changes it would have to be done
by a completely different mechanism
okay representative van halton
oh i'm sorry i will lower my hand i
apologize okay uh representative herbert
you there chris chris you're muted
yeah sorry i'm i uh there there is a
constituency or several constituencies
out there
who i think uh
uh require
paper billing
and uh
and i'm concerned about anything that
might cause
someone
to get charged
you know overdraft fees
or late fees on credit
and so as a result of that
i'm i'm pretty sure that
if everybody went to
electronic billing
there would be a number of number of
people who would uh
suffer so i'm not
i'm not ready to uh
[Music]
vote for this uh
bill
bill for the motion
okay
uh any more discussion on the motion of
any expedient to legislate i assume
you're you just have to retreat okay
okay what do you want who was the second
uh uh
thank
you
okay any uh more discussion seeing none
the clerk will call the roll
okay the motion is itl on house bill 76.
uh calling the role uh vice chairman
john patusik yes
representative jason osborne oh you
didn't say your name kate
your third
on
i'm jason's second on the list
okay is that all right yep that's fine
mr chairman could could keith
say exactly again exactly what we're
voting on here emotion the motion sorry
i will it's my job to make sure you're
clear on the motion the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
okay okay so i started with vice
chairman he voted yes john patusik
uh representative jason osborne
yes
representative keith hammond that's me
representative max abramson
yes
yes okay
representative joseph de palma
yes
representative jeffrey greeson
representative don johnson
johnson yes
representative paul terry
yes
representative christy bartlett
no
representative rich abel
representative christopher herbert no
representative connie van halten
no
representative christina fargo
yes
joyce weston
representative jane bellew
no
representative anita burroughs no
representative
chris mcaleer
yes
and
chairman representative john hunt
you're missing i know yes and the phone
was ringing so your yes is that yes i'm
assuming okay
all right uh let's see that is uh
the vote is 13 to 6
and the motion passes
okay uh would there be a minority report
yes
okay
all right and who sorry who's writing
the minority report i'll do it
christy
okay representative bartlett yes
okay
um are we gonna get forms
for that
uh pam are we sending out forms to
people or
no i think just an email um we'll we'll
do it for them yeah so both
yeah for you representation for you
just send send the email to me and then
i will forward it on to pam
the form asks me for the minority motion
is that retain oh that's right but your
her motion would be retained okay
yes
uh is it customary for the uh
since i'm a freshman yeah legislator uh
is it customary for the move or the
motion to automatically uh write the
maturity report that is uh traditional
so so the clerk so noted that yeah well
you know i was i was going to mention
that i i'm going to assume that whoever
made the motion will do the majority
report thank you for that assumption is
that and then but um once you do it you
just email it to me yes well thank you
for that great honor and that
clarification thank you and uh
um so
okay uh
chrissy do you have another question you
have your hand up
nope unintentionally okay now paul you
can take your hands off good get all the
hands down all right so now we can go
are we ready time for our public hearing
and
okay
so uh
we have about 10 minutes yeah i think
we're early
what did i do that for
[Laughter]
enough practice
that's you know i was out of shape for
two years you know two years and i
didn't have anything to do with it but i
thought i did pretty good yesterday this
morning and yesterday we got through it
so it's dead so far so good
these split notices are confusing some
of us
um yes so i'll just just review that for
everybody so again technology is uh
where we now are at the mercy of of our
new software system and everybody will
always tell you that anytime you have a
new software it's uh you have new new
things that you were never expected or
used to
so what's going happening going forward
from now now whereas before i would just
list
or we would you know but like so it's
not just me the previous
previous chair the same thing you would
just we would list all the bills that
would be exact
now we have to put him in his time
specific when we're
the only
benefit this is to a chairman
who's scheduling it
is to uh
schedule it tight
because you don't want to have like this
lull that we're having now
so but it's okay to
be late
which does not make sense to me you know
because it seems a little rude to make
people sit in but i would say there are
times when we when we have exact very
large pile when we have a large pile of
bills and we start out at 10 o'clock or
whatever the exact session and the room
would be packed full of people
and so my tendency was usually to look
around and see
what bills they were here for and try to
you know weed through and pick out the
bills that i could try to weed out the
crowd um and then or whether there was a
department if there's some department
you know if they're a commissioner
sitting in the room i definitely want to
take care of that bill right away but
so with this new system
um everything is time certain
and uh but i obviously i do have the the
we have to push push someone off if
we're running late but which i don't
think is a good thing to do it is what
it is so my hands up
okay
yes chris
yeah
um earlier on
you went through the
um the benefits of uh retaining
a bill
and i think had uh
that's why i voted the way i did
with the idea of retention
so um
because i don't think i don't think
anybody was
thought this bill was
ready for prime time as it were
um but if if we kill it like this is it
more difficult it does it have to be
reintroduced i mean what are the uh what
is the hurdle we put in front of this
this idea
by going itl
versus retention uh well technically
yeah so uh so technically we would have
uh were our session in february uh this
february 24th i guess 25th
and which uh if the bill is um
if the house does kill the bill then um
theoretically it is dead for the the
biennium that it cannot be reintroduced
um having said that um you all you have
to do is change the way the bill was
written and do it in a different way
like put it under consumer protection or
do something different with it um and
suddenly the bill will have life
come next year
so i mean i've seen that happen a lot so
but technically i think that you know at
least um in terms of my caucus it was
pretty much that that that
there is no way no way you're going to
do this unless you want to treat it as
like an elderly exemption
um there was no way we were really going
to be able to implement it and even then
it how do you enforce that you know an
elderly exemption so
um that's why the uh
you know the motion was inexpedient
so
and i always say every bill has a grain
of truth to it
every bill does but some of them it's
just the devil's in the details
so yes chrissy you know we have too many
chris on this committee you know yeah we
do have a lot of christmas
um
i was just wondering if you would mind
just kind of reiterating what's going on
um
the
the schedule for next week we had an
awful lot of notices
yes okay you did ask me about that yeah
okay so so um getting back to this this
problematic
system of the dates every the time
certain so
when you're getting these notices where
before
if we were doing an exact session that
day it would be listed on that same
sheet of paper but because of this new
software the new system
um executing a bill is treated as a
totally different
um memo and and i i guess in defense of
the computer it is it is true that the
um
it
it has to go and see who all the
sponsors are and notify them
that it's occurring which should still
be happening even when we schedule the
bill so i don't know why the computer
feels compelled to do this but when it
comes to exec session
it really wants to treat it as though
it's a different day even though it's
the same day
does anybody have any questions um about
the notices that we received yesterday
okay
and of course always look at the
calendar if that helps you too
yeah
well the count you know hopefully the
calendar well we'll see what the
calendar
how the calendar treats this
but
uh but i guess other committees exactly
now they've the exact same day i don't
think has anybody scheduled an exact
session on the calendar i don't remember
seeing that but
yes representative johnson
so
did everybody see
um the email that went out i got it at
lunch about the new
online version of the calendar where you
can click on the different information
sessions and
links for all the different committee
meetings and stuff i just figured i
happened to see it at when we were on
lunch
so i wanted to just make sure everybody
know it was out there it looks kind of
easy and fun to use i don't know
i'm still an old-fashioned girl i like
my paper
just kind of you know bring that to
somebody's attention if they haven't
seen
the emails yet
yeah and and the other thing i can't
emphasize enough is that if you are
going to testify if you don't want to be
sure you do it the night before
so uh reason saying that representative
greeson you didn't actually sign up for
your own bills
to speak on your own bills and i know
you you're a freshman so you probably
didn't know you were supposed to do that
but
in the old days you know when the
committee we would just say all right
fill out a pink card
and we know you know go ahead and
testify but obviously we have this new
new
whiz-bang system and so yeah the night
before you need to sign up um and and
what really important and i can't
emphasize this enough because this gets
me in good with my clerks
is that if you are going to do a
testimony if you are going to write
something up just submit it at the same
time when you sign up and that will make
make the clerk love you
yes can i add something right
on the subject i'm sorry to interrupt
but
if you happen to not sign in but but do
speak just as in the
when we meet in person we ask somebody
to fill out a pink card sort of after
they speak often we ask you to register
after you speak because and for that
reason we are printing the the final
testimony sheets
the day after the hearing to capture
those people that's that volunteered you
know raise their hand to speak but have
not made the registration cut off
okay okay so that's great but uh so you
you wanted i guess i needed to contact
ned gordon and tell him he needed to
do that because
um
i haven't been monitoring who's not on
your list
and i had to hand write him in
oh okay yeah we need to get him into the
system i'll look i'll go through this
but i think he's never written yeah he's
the only one but okay
yes joyce
so just to clarify should i go
i i introduced a bill yesterday should i
go in and sign in for that testimony
even though i was in the committee it
was your yes you need a pin card if
you're you know a committee member
normally so yeah it's the same process
okay i'll go back and do it thank you
yeah and nothing else is important just
so you're on record that you did testify
you were here and you did testify even
though we've got youtube to prove it but
you
know i i actually that's the reason why
i want to send you have you know all you
guys get these sheets because it has the
person's phone number so if you wanted
to someone testify and said something
and you want to follow up with them it's
nice to have their phone number right
there
can i just clarify
if i testified on a bill i sponsored
yesterday in judiciary i signed in do i
need to do anything else now no as long
as you signed in you're good yeah
but like i say but if you want to endear
yourself to the to the clerk is is to
whatever testimony you had or type what
you typed up is just to you know
add that upload that oh you send it to
paul as well
uh no no no just upload it on that
screen don't and this is probably oh
okay can i go back and do it now because
i didn't
uh uh well she'd be getting yesterday so
i don't know pam didn't okay i didn't
know i was supposed to upload that okay
good to know
you can
send your testimony to the
committee's distribution list oh i did i
did that okay then you're covered you
don't just need to submit it once okay
if you did that then you're all good
yeah but that's the point anyway so that
is a nice feature of this sign up is
that when you sign up you submit that
testimony so that goes to the clerk but
then goes to all the committee members
automatically okay it really is a you
know
it's and it's the committee clerk that
we're referring to because it's the
committee clerk that takes the notes
of each hearing not paul smith okay
right excuse me
yes
i'm sorry
[Music]
on your last um
executive session on the on the house
bill 76 yes i had some doubt about the
the
ability of a minority report to be
retained and so i emailed our clerk paul
smith to see if
you know to refresh my memory before i
gave you information and he says you
cannot retain as a minority because it
doesn't come to the floor
okay
so what should the motion be
the party
yeah they have to be out to pass then
oh yuck so oh this is
no that kind of makes sense
yes we used to have a
re-refer for interim study so when they
changed that the re they've changed it
yeah i'm i'm i had a doubt
he wrote me back and that's that's his
answer so i
i'll put something in the note that'll
make it clear
there you go all's been wrong before
right but you're gonna have to motion's
gonna have to write it as otp but
if you want to have fun with it you
could make it up an amendment
and it doesn't have to be an amendment
that the committee ever saw you can make
up an amendment and say out to pass with
an amendment that's more work than i'm
willing to put into it well i mean i've
just for discussion just to humor you i
would if i were in your shoes if i were
in the mirror and i wanted to do that um
the amendment i would submit would be a
study committee
right you of all people
yeah
i think that makes more sense because i
wouldn't have voted otp
well
mr chair you would never vote for study
committee if you could that's not true i
have done plenty i just when i do a
study committee i wanted to be very
narrow very narrow and really you know
right to the subject matter and
not be true
okay uh
don you put your hand down so you your
question was answered yeah it basically
was because one next week
i will be introducing two bills in in
commerce
so uh
i i will have to sign up
to testify on them
correct
yes okay okay so representative johnson
did were you all said and i know you had
to have that question
pm could answer
i had asked to get copies of the bills i
got the first set of bills in the mail
and they said they were still waiting
for the rest of the printing to come in
do you know the status on that pam
i don't i know that a lot of mailings
have gone out but i haven't been
involved with them
okay no i'll print them off that's fine
thank you
okay all right so let's uh let's open up
the public hearing
and
the first bill here is uh house bill 264
the prime sponsor
representative mclean
and memphis maclean you want to raise
your hand so i can
see you there there you are
okay
uh you know what pam you got to turn me
back on i i
got out
pam
i was working on it
sorry sorry i should have told you i i
logged out on my computer and
okay unmuting i was working
multitasking okay representative mclean
welcome to the commerce committee
uh thank you mr chair and honorable
members of the commerce committee for
the record my name is mark mclean
representing hillsborough 44 which is
southern manchester and the town of
litchfield i'm here today to introduce
hb 264 which requires that health care
providers provide the patient upon
request
a price quote for non-emergency health
care services
and i'm going to illustrate why the bill
is needed uh with two quick examples um
the first is that my wife is a
sonographer at a hospital i won't name
and a patient from brazil came in with
severe pain and they wanted to do an
ultrasound on them but he had heard that
health care in america was expensive and
he had no insurance
so he wanted to know the cost prior to
agreeing to have any procedure done on
them
but they wouldn't give him the cost and
in the end they let him leave
undiagnosed and in pain rather than
provide them the cost and i think that
that's wrong and um on a personal note
uh the second situation i was in a minor
car accident two years ago
because it was minor i notified my
insurance company but i didn't file a
claim but my wife insisted i go in and
get a check up just to make sure you
know that's kind of how she is so when i
got to the urgent care because i had not
filed a claim i just told them look i'm
going to be paying out of my own pocket
for this so i asked them how much the
checkup was going to cost it was going
to be one or two hundred dollars i'd go
forward with the exam keep my wife happy
but if it's going to be a thousand
dollars i was feeling pretty good and i
said obviously i don't want to go
forward with the exam in that case again
they couldn't even give me a ballpark
answer even in the case where this is
just a simple exam and i was going to be
paying directly out of my pocket so
these are two examples of very simple
procedures just imagine the uncertainty
that consumers feel when they have to
navigate their way through very complex
medical procedures and imagine
their shock when they open up a bill
that they had no idea uh was coming and
i'm sure that many of you on this
committee have experienced this and
providing some form of upfront pricing
it's just going to allow people to plan
and maybe seek out treatment when the
fear of unknown costs might keep them
away and also introduce some market
forces to the healthcare arena so
i went through three draftings of the
language of this bill consulting uh the
co-sponsors and former health care
billers as i went along so we put in
provisions for itemization so that would
make cost comparisons easy for the
consumers
we allowed three days to provide the
quote and in the final draft we
eliminated any binding provisions on the
quotes to mitigate
the risk for the providers um but but
here's the rub when i spoke with the
policy experts in the insurance
department
they still felt
that
the technical challenges involved in
providing individualized quotes that
were going to have any value for the
consumer it was just too overwhelming
they felt that
the problems with the reimbursement
model coupled with the complexities of
incorporating third party
uh were just too much
and therefore the bill as it was written
actually would have the unintended
consequence of driving costs up and that
is going in the opposite direction
of where i obviously want to go
so i mean after those discussions i
really struggled a lot with how to
proceed and i seriously considered
pulling the bill but in the end i
decided to move forward with the bill
and because i recognize as i think
everybody on this committee does on that
the problem is real and at some point it
does need to be addressed so while i
know that the bill can't be
passed in its current form i hope that
you know while you recognize the flaws
in the bill you also recognize that the
problem is still persisting and that
you'll retain the bill and pull in some
of the subject experts from the industry
to maybe start to tackle the issue i
really think that's where the solutions
are going to come from and it's going to
be an iterative process so uh so the
journey to full transparency it's going
to be a long one it's going to be a
difficult one but i really think that at
some point we have to start walking
so
i do hope that you will consider
retaining the bill and that's my
testimony and i'll answer any questions
or attempt to answer any questions you
may have
uh we do have questions
um let's see who was first and first up
was
was representing then
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative um i'm glad that you said
to retain because i do see that there
are issues and i know that we've had
emails about those issues um one of the
things you didn't address is the solo
health care provider or the two or three
uh health office health care provider um
and and the honoris task that this might
be for them to do this within a three
day period with current procedural
terminology as well what would you
suggest as a fix for those people
um you know
i don't i don't have the answer as i
said when i when i talk to the folks
when i when i talked with the health
care billers um i was left with the
impression that as you go forward you're
often getting pre-approval from the
insurance companies
so i was left when i was drafting the
bill with the impression that that would
be less onerous than it was so when i
was again talking to the folks with the
insurance department they said i know
that's not necessarily the case so maybe
um
uh the
the first step in this might be to say
you know what we're just going to just
carve it out and look at people who are
making uh direct payments or something
of that nature um as i said it's it's
gonna maybe have to start with uh a
smaller model um and maybe if you retain
it you might say these are areas and
these are providers that maybe have the
resources let's start there let's narrow
the scope of who has to provide it let's
narrow the scope of the situations where
it would have to be provided
to start to to build the model so i
recognize your concern and it is
problematic thank you
okay representative johnson is next
so i appreciate you
coming before us thank you let me ask my
question my question is
on most insurance companies if like even
if i wanted to
um
do something like pay out of my pocket
for a procedure
most insurance companies will also help
you i know i can call multiple doctors
in hospitals now and they will give me
quotes
so isn't this already an option
and why would we need to put it into law
if it's already being done by the
insurance companies and by the providers
if you call and ask because i know i
have i get i can do that at any time
um
thank you for the question
that has not been my experience um
um
it that just hasn't been my experience
so i i would
i would love to talk to you offline
about that and
if that is
the case
then it may speak to the fact that the
journey may not be as difficult um
as it is i mean if if they're if they
are able to provide that to you as you
say
um then maybe there is a model that
could be expanded upon um it has just
not been my experience or the experience
of my constituents that that is the case
okay uh representative abramson who's
next
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative mclean for taking uh my
question
um looking at the bill um
would you be amenable to simply uh
deleting
where it says for example i an itemized
cost quote from all non-emergency
services just remove itemized
and then uh not including third-party
services and then delete the last part
because i i i think what it sounded like
based on your testimony was you want to
see you know what am i paying
if i
get this service here and is this going
to be too much money and then making the
decision based on the bottom line
in other words just a bottom line cost
quote
well i mean i think um
the reason that i look to have it
the goal ultimately representative
abramson is to have something that has
value to the consumer um so
i i sometimes
you might get a a bottom line quote
that's just a bottom line quote um from
one provider that uh
is contains different things than a
quote you might get from from somebody
else um so if you could do it in a way
that it would make it meaningless
but if you could do it in a way i mean
or
an option might be if you left it
itemized but did not put in the third
party just put down these are my cpt
codes but these are all third-party
provided i mean
i don't want to jump to what the what
the solution is but at the end of the
day
the goal would be to
give
the the consumer something that is
meaningful and useful to them
right now they have something on the the
u.s health cost
which is on the nh.gov website is on a
sub tab where you can go in and you can
say look at i want to get a gallbladder
surgery and um i want to get it you know
at i put in that i have for example a
harvard pilgrim and it will tell me the
hospitals and what it costs
but
are they all including the same thing
are they not all including the same
thing uh on some of that it says it's
highly accurate on some hospitals as
this is very low accuracy when i talk to
the folks
in the insurance department about what
drives that level of accuracy
they're really soft on that um it's just
aggregated data so um i guess i would be
agreeable to everything that you would
propose as long as in the end
it provided some value to the consumer
okay fair enough all right
representative burrows
thank you and thank you for taking my
question good to hear your voice
representative mclean um
i i guess my question is whether you
know um when you say healthcare provider
i i assume that could mean individual
health care providers or
or a small group of health care
providers
correct
follow-up please another question you
may inquire
okay um so my question is
um are you aware that many healthcare
providers do not unders don't know the
codes the the um cpt codes they don't
know the codes and the value of the
codes and the second part of it is when
they're calculating costs there's also a
facilities cost that um
is calculated in the cost so those are
those things that you'll also be looking
at
um
and and that's exactly you know building
on the point that representative van
houghton brought up so yes i mean it it
it is problematic okay
thank you
and
representative fargo
um yes i
thank you mr chair um
having had
several non-emergency type
surgeries myself like hip replacements
and knee replacements
um there's a lot of things that are
unpredictable that can happen to you
when you're in that process so
you could be given a quote but then
have
a medical emergency or have something
unusual happen or have to see an
additional specialist and i don't know
how you could hold a provider to a quote
when each individual case may be
different how would you address that
um well um the
in the final draft all the binding
provisions uh were taken out of it you
know for that very reason because um a
lot of the the healthcare individual
health the pardon my the healthcare
industry today is is managing risk and
so uh
so i took those because out because if
you made a quote that was binding
that would i think have just been too
much because
the risk is just too great and the other
thing that
does not apply in the original bill
is
any emergency care so it exclusively
addresses non-emergency care so
obviously if you are in the middle of a
routine non-emergency procedure but an
emergency event arises like you have a
bleed out or something like that
that's an emergency event
that is not covered under the provisions
of the bill you know but again um
even whether it's covered or not covered
i recognize even this language um needs
to be worked on so this would this would
definitely not be the final language
that could uh that could uh go to the
house
okay great thank you very much for your
testimony
uh
chair well then call on paula minahan
and
okay there you are
and bringing you the panels
okay paula you're on
oh she will be sorry about that um can
you hear me yes we can great sorry about
that there was a little delay good
afternoon mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state
the hospital association is opposed to
house bill 264 um and i wanted to just
clarify a few things i know a lot of you
know me
from years past um so
um i will just kind of i've submitted my
testimony which is kind of long but it
provided a lot of um background that i
thought might be helpful for you um but
i just want to clarify the bill um
is amending 151 rsa 151 that is specific
to health care facilities
so i think to answer representative
burroughs question does not incorporate
any of the private
doctors offices provider offices so
that's important for folks to understand
they are not licensed
as a health care facility in the state
of new hampshire their private doctors
offices fall under the board of medicine
and do not require
a specific facility license
um
as representative fargo indicated
there are a lot of um unassoci un
identified potentially um emergency
services that might result in in
addition to a non-emergent service and
that is really our issue with the
hospitals and again anyone that has
heard me testify on similar bills in the
past
knows that um they they are complex um
so what hospitals have done
voluntarily for years
is um to provide these
tools
and i would say i don't speak obviously
for the carriers but they also have
tools um and then if you're uninsured
151 colon 12
there is an uninsured law on the state
on the on the books in new hampshire
that actually provides a pretty
substantial discount for anyone that is
uninsured um so getting a quote um is a
little more challenging but they
certainly the hospitals do that um so
what the hospitals try to do is to
provide accurate and relevant cost
information
that that may include out-of-pocket cost
calculators on the hospitals have
created tools on that um they've
invested in technology to streamline the
process of getting information to the
patient and they provide a phone number
um readily available on their website
to assist
patients so what they really have done
is they try to uh make it really easy
for the hot the patient to actually call
the hospital and have that conversation
as representative fargo said if you're
getting a total knee replacement there
are a lot of components to that beyond
just getting a um going on a website and
and getting a
an estimate you need have the
anesthesiologist the physician
um the hospital or if it's an uh
ambulatory surgery center attached to
the hospital you gotta
get that information so that's what they
do they really focus on trying to be
very specific
um and but more importantly and it's um
i think it's new information that maybe
some of you are not aware but the
federal government implemented a
hospital transparency regulation in 2019
that was phased in the last couple years
i
incorporate i included your the um
the link to the to the website the cms
website um on in my testimony
but a lot in that there was a component
that was passed in 2019 for that went
into effect in 2020 and now there's a
brand new one um that is even more
elaborate and um and detailed that went
into effect last month in january 2021
hospitals in new hampshire have spent a
considerable time effort and financial
resources to implement this rule they're
substantial uh substantive excuse me and
we do not believe additional
requirements should be imposed on our
hospitals at this time
um and despite the major the major
expanse of this rule again we we believe
it's best that the hospitals and the
patients talk directly to get a more
meaningful
um estimate um that will be more
relevant for the for the patient um so
i'm happy to answer any questions but we
do not believe that this um bill is
necessary and we ask that
you not um you find it inexpedient to
legislate i'm happy to answer any
questions
okay yeah before i take a question um
it's funny because you said 155 and just
dragged my memory because i know many
moons ago
uh there used to be a
patient's bill of rights under that that
hospital statute
and isn't one of them one of the statute
requirements in 155 is to is to give a
rough look of what the what the uh
what it's going to cost
upon request yes yes you're right
representative so i was going to say
this is already law theoretically
um it's i think i got to pull up 150 um
what is the patient bill of rights i
should know it by heart but i don't know
why i'm asking you
i know um i i'll look it up um
that was just my that was my when he
said one two it dawned on me that that
was it's um the patient that's primarily
for inpatient i think and it's upon
request but yes you're right it's 151
colon 21
is the patient bill of rights but you're
right it is incorporated into that
but this is more the bill um represented
mclean's bill obviously is more than
just hospitals as he mentioned urgent
care centers um
would fall under this but doctors
offices don't and i just wanted to make
that point um because i don't know that
everyone understands
what 151 incorporates and what it does
not got it okay
representative herbert your your hand is
up but i'm not sure you're with us that
was a mistake because you took yourself
video off so are you
okay wait a minute
i took i forgot about the video part
um no i was uh just a couple
observations number one is uh
i remember you
i remember your question right you could
do a question or yes
i did it did you not uh
make reference to we like to get a
written testimony in
and i i
and isn't it true
that that is aimed at uh not extending
the uh conversation
beyond
uh uh
unnecessarily especially if there's
written testimony
and that so i what i'm trying to get at
is that
the uh sponsor of this bill
uh has already told us that it is not
ready for prime time
and and as a result of that
i thought we might uh figure out how to
move it move it somewhere else and then
have a sufficient time in order to
actually look at the bill
in depth i didn't think we were going to
do it today i think that's uh
over
a bridge too far when the sponsor
himself is not all that comfortable uh
with
the bill itself as it currently stands
it's just that i you know i'm old i
don't have as many days in front of me
as i did before so i like to get things
done as efficiently as possible if you
don't mind uh
so go ahead and tune yourself out go go
do what you old geezers like to do and
but yes i still got to go through the
hearing and have everybody testify
and and have the questions and that i'm
i'm obligated to do to do that hearing
i'm still listening i just uh okay i
make faces and stuff like that yeah so
well i did see you make a face last time
and i was glad you turned your camera
off okay represent hamilton
yeah thank you mr chair thank you for
your testimony um i guess in the spirit
of streamlining
uh you mentioned in your testimony and i
was vaguely aware of this but i don't
know the details these new requirements
these new transparency requirements
coming from the federal government
you mentioned they were phased in
and the most recent went into effect
january 1st of this year
is that correct um
does that accomplish some of the things
that uh representative mclean's bill is
attempting to accomplish and
uh
would it be a good idea to allow those
new regs to settle before
putting additional
burdens on to hospitals
um
i'm not sure that the federal
regulations although they are expansive
um they require lots of posting of
information on the hospital's websites
that is very detailed um
but um to be um perfectly um
on uh frank um we as the hospital
industry had concerns about these
regulations when they were introduced
and and promulgated by um the previous
administration because
they are not what i would call consumer
friendly um they are very very very
detailed with detailed charges
difficult for an individual going into a
hospital for like a total knee
replacement to actually figure out
what it's going to cost them um and
furthermore as someone else indicated
because when you have insurance it is a
whole different dynamic because the
insurance
company actually is more effective i
would say in bit in being able to help
that consumer figure out what their
out-of-pocket will be
um so while i think it was an attempt to
make the um
the charges i guess of the hospitals
more
transparent to the consumer our concern
as a hospital industry is it's just too
much in the weeds and it really does not
help the consumer necessarily figure out
what they what their cost is having said
all that um back to your question about
the the bill before you
um we have
other concerns about this putting this
into law we're doing it voluntarily um
i'm not sure about the specificity with
the three days and the specifics with
the cpts except like i said
that's when the patient
will call the hospital talk to the right
financial patient representative and
work through that
to find out exactly what that person is
the doctor has said they need
they get then they do the estimate um so
i guess i would say we don't need the we
don't believe it the bill is necessary
because the hospitals are providing to
the to the extent that they're able
um this this information now um
but like you said the new law or the new
reg it's not a law the new regulation
went into effect like you said a month
ago um we do need to see what
transpires as a result of that there's
also another piece of that law
that impacts the cons the carriers and
that goes into effect in 2022 um so it's
really really expansive um legislation
uh excuse me i keep saying like
regulation um and it's um i think we
need some time to see how it plays out i
think you you bring up a very good point
representative
okay all set
uh no more hands up and we're all set
thank you paula
and last but not least is tyler brennan
from the new hampshire insurance
department
thank you um by the brandon with the
insurance department and the department
does not have a position on the bill but
we have been a long time supporter of
price transparency in general
our new hampshire health cost website in
early 2007
largely because of
the legislative legislature's interest
in price transparency among health care
providers
the website's received a fair amount of
attention
and
both nationally and we're still really
considered new hampshire is considered
the benchmark
price transparency because of the effort
around that website
that being said i can't over overstate
kind of the complexity of trying to
provide
consumer friendly format
for people to use and
you've got so many different moving
parts
um between the reimbursement systems and
the payments going to different
providers that are involved in
particular service and even who the
patient would see as provider is it
going to be the physician is it going to
be the hospital the surgery center is it
going to be the group practice that
they're a part of
so
framing the data in such a way it's
actually useful and the analysis or the
way the methodology is applied
consistently
these are some some challenging areas to
work through so i think what a good
example is some even something as simple
as a mammogram tends to have a
professional and a technical component
but even better not all the time
sometimes it's just built globally so if
you want to know the price of a
mammogram you might go to a hospital and
ask and they might just tell you the
technical component the amount they're
paid for it and in fact a hospital did
that a number of years ago and they
looked really inexpensive because
they didn't include the radiologist that
didn't actually work for the hospital
i heard from a radiologist when we first
put up the website who said yeah you've
got our group practice up there but i
don't think the rate is right and they
were quite specific to anthem and this
is one of the only examples where we
heard from a provider and they were
right we were posting their rates but
sometimes the group practice build a
global rate which was just the group
practice billing it other times they
worked at the local hospital in which
case the hospital reimbursement portion
was more than what the group practice
would have normally seen
our methodology would just bundle the
services together regardless of where
this particular radiology group was
performing the service and
separate those two so clarify if you
went to the hospital if you went to the
group practice
so there are a lot of challenges in
producing information like this we do
include a kind of a field that gives you
a sense of how accurate our estimate is
and one of the reasons the accuracy can
suffer is we're looking at actual
patient experiences so we use our
anonymous claims data to produce the
price estimates but the reality is
sometimes every patient's experience is
different from the other even at the
same provider can't always explain why
that's the case but if you've got 10
different patients they all had 10
different total price for their services
um we can't provide an estimate with a
lot of confidence so that's one of the
biggest reasons for that field if you
actually want to know how that field is
is created it's it's based on the
coefficient of variation which is the
standard deviation is a percentage of
the mean but that's not something we
normally throw out there um so if we
suggested that kind of a legislation
like this might increase cost it
probably was just along the lines that
um if the intention is to have whatever
thousands of providers in new hampshire
producing price information um that may
not be uh in the same consumer-friendly
format then you've got the
administrative cost of producing the
information out there potentially
without the benefit and
based on history most of the price
transparency initiatives
haven't resulted in consumer friendly
information
so
that's kind of a general overview of
what we've done and some of the
challenges in producing useful price
price transparency information but happy
to to take any questions
okay uh representative abramson has a
question
uh thank you mr chair and
uh thank you for taking my question um
so this bill would be added if it were
passed as is to rsa 151 section 12 b
which is hospital rates for self-pay
patients
um do you think would you see any
problem with simply adding
this language
um stating that the
the hospital which presumably has the
self-pay patient rate that they would
just
tell the the patient
or tell the buyer right then
what that cost is before they buy it
in other words just add it right into
the
patient bill of rights
so i think it would have to include
enough clarification for the hospital to
provide what at best would still be an
estimate and it would just be for the
hospital services so that could be
misleading because when you go to the
hospital you're never going to get a
bill just for hospital services so um i
mean you have to remember sometimes
hospitals are paid on a discount from
charges from sure sometimes they
calculate their rates based on sort of a
per case payment that medicare might use
for payment there are a lot of different
ways of looking at it so it's um i think
it still has a number of challenges
obviously if you narrow the requirement
as much as possible then um then it's
potentially simpler to uh to implement
uh follow-up for the question inquire
um i well i guess what i'm getting at is
just you know there's there's a rate
that the hospital already knows that
they have to
um
you know charge self-pay patients
obviously leaving out third party
um uh third-party providers if they
don't have that information there only
uh requiring it if they do have that
information there at the time that the
patient goes in
and asks
um
would you see a a problem with rewriting
the bill that way
well i think the important thing to
remember about hospitals particularly
when they're dealing with the uninsured
so it might be the expectation that they
give an uninsured person a sort of a
discount from charges that's similar to
what they would give
a commercially insured patient but i
think the reality is that hospitals will
often look at a patient's financial
situation and they'll go through a set
of financial counseling and figure out
what how much of the original bill
they're going to actually waive so
there's sort of a floor that might be
expected and that's actually what we use
for our health cost website if you go to
the uninsured section we've obtained
information from the hospitals but it's
just an estimate
of what what percentage of charges um
the patient would be liable for but the
reality is they actually might get a
much better deal by working with the
hospital so i think similarly it could
not it could be misleading to the extent
it doesn't accurately represent what a
patient's experience will be when they
go there
all right fair enough
all right representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
mr brennan
can you give me an idea of how often
they um whoever
tracks these pricing
um
the prices on the website has to be
updated my i mean i have to guess that
it's got to be a moving target how could
you keep this up to date
yeah that's a great question we um
we used to do it quarterly so we get new
data on a quarterly basis and we used to
update the website as often as quarterly
we now do it twice a year and there are
going to be changes in healthcare
they're going to be changes in the
contracts and they're going to be
changes um really in the way the
services are delivered so um you know
for example even the kind of the the way
of delivering colonoscopies is changing
a bit and you may not always have a
an anesthesiologist or or certain key
players involved but the biggest thing
we saw was just looking at the prices
over time and seeing how they might go
up and trying to report on on data that
that is a year or year and a half long
but the contract changed halfway through
that year you want enough data to
produce a reliable estimate but at the
same time you have to recognize there
have been changes during the time frame
that you're reporting on so that's one
of the reasons we refer to it as an
estimate it's based on real experiences
but those real experiences will have
changed over time so um yeah it is a
certainly a challenge when you're
looking at uh prices and and how they
they will go up and usually they go up
occasionally they go down
okay my followers look at that
thanks very much
at lunchtime today i paid bills
and
this is a would you believe
i from concord hospital my husband had a
procedure done in january 2020.
um the bill came in
on january the 5th
this year
and the doctor's charges were 17
with a 13 000
discount
um there were other professional fees of
three thousand with the discount of
twenty six hundred
um
how anybody can figure out
what the real cost is beyond me i don't
know how you do it at the insurance
department
yeah so i do believe your example and
what we do is we are using actual claims
so um in the example you had we would we
would see both the charge and we would
see the actual amount due so when i say
mountain dew it includes what the
insurer paid but includes any cost
sharing due from the patient as well so
we use the charges only to the extent
that we're sort of tracking one patient
experience to the next let's see if
there's a lot of variation but we're
actually looking at the prices paid
because they're going to be different
between an anthem and a cigna or harvard
so that's why we we haven't reported at
the actual insurer level but sort of
adding to to kind of the point you're
trying to make i've heard from
healthcare providers occasionally when
they were for example a surgery center
and they were questioning the price we
had on health cost and i said well do
you realize what the physicians are paid
and what and they said no but i can't
believe it's that high and i need to
come back and say well well actually it
is it's this
two of those physicians involved and
that's going to reason for the total so
that gives you a sense of how even
within an organization they may not
understand some of the the variation or
some of the charges versus the amount
paid that that you've given as an
example
thank you
so well said that
yeah
okay uh seeing no more questions i guess
we're all set and uh
but i would say it uh tyler i in my
memory it took us a couple of years to
figure out all the different
pieces to get them to report
and we had several different legis
pieces of legislation to finally get all
those pieces to get them to report all
these different numbers and
is that is that my memory correct on
that
um
so
you may be talking about going back to
2003 when the legislation was actually
being done so we got the data in
2005-ish that was what started he
collected i came to the department 2006
we got the up on the website in early
2007 there were fewer procedures then
but i think during the time frame since
then we at one time were explored
getting down on the uninsured another
time we've had to deal with the go bag
versus liberty mutual which had to deal
with self-funded so there have been some
revisiting of the statute but i think to
the extent that um we're producing
information um it's largely done the
same way as it used to but um we uh but
we have a lot more services and we
actually even have a downloadable
template that's designed for healthcare
providers and insurers that show data at
the cpt code level it's not very
consumer friendly but it hopefully will
lead to a more efficient market as
people better understand the price of
health care services
okay cool
all right well thank you very much thank
you i have no one else who would like to
testify on this bill so uh and no more
hands up so i will close the public
hearing on house bill 264.
yeah
time being 227 how are we doing with the
next bill here
okay
all right so we're all right so now
we're
fine okay
so representative greeson's up for your
next two bills here
and
given that we're past time so
we can
full steam ahead
so we'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 488
establishing committee to study the
benefits allowing new hampshire citizens
to purchase health insurance from out of
state
companies
and
representative griezmann are you ready
to testify
yes sir thank you and thank you uh
committee members uh so this was my
first stab at a legis proposal for
legislation uh
with so many representatives on all
sides trying to
find ways of reducing health care costs
especially the out-of-pocket costs
consumers must pay including premiums
and co-pays associated with their health
insurance policies medications and
medical treatments outside of their
insurance
with such a noble goal this is not an
easy problem to fix and it's sort of
like the mythical creature hydra when
you lop off one head two more grow back
this bill had the intention of seeking
solutions
uh with with the objective of bringing
down health care costs but i think it's
not exploring in a right direction
i know that there are other uh bills
proposed that i think may uh may
may be going in a better direction uh
the the thought was to table this one
and refine it
to make sure that it is going to to
potentially find solutions uh to just
simply go out and say find something
across state lines uh is too broad or
may not find anything it would and
therefore would be counterproductive so
if we if we
narrow the scope or give it a little bit
better direction i think that would be
uh would be beneficial
at this point to not kill it necessarily
because i think we need to find
solutions but give it better direction
that's all i have okay
uh representative burroughs has her hand
up
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question
representative i guess it's a two-prong
question um
uh which is if there are three members
of the house house of representatives
appointed by the speaker and one member
of the senate appointed by the president
of the senate um do you think this would
be a bipartisan commission uh and do you
think that that would be important
i think a bipartisan commission would be
important uh
again there are there are people on all
sides seeking solutions
um there there's no
uh no one party has a solution no one
person probably has a solution if they
do i'd like to find them um so
who comprises uh the study uh
is immaterial to me as long as they are
honest about their intentions and are
truly seeking a solution and not just
using it as partisan politics
thank you okay
next up representative bartlett
you mr chair
representative greece
we struggle with this
year after year and there are various
kinds of
study committees that we tried to pull
together
um
i think last time everything got
tabled after or went to the senate and
got killed i don't remember which um
but if you're really thinking that this
is too broad
would you consider withdrawing it
and trying to come up with a bill that's
much more narrow
that that
might
there there is no i have enough interest
there is no withdrawal you can't always
know what's wrong you can't withdraw
bill you can
all you do is come to the committee and
say
uh you know kill it or pass it you know
or i mean i think it's
i think you're very well intentioned and
i think there's lots of us here that
would like to figure out some solutions
but this is so broad
with only four people
there's no way they're going to be able
to do this
that's my thought
and that's why the committee can vote in
expedient to legislate or we can make a
motion to table so
retain we could retain it
or we can itl it
but
obviously ought to pass is probably not
going to work
okay uh representative abramson
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative greeson for taking my
question i actually had almost the uh
the opposite
uh impression that it only deals with
one way of
reducing costs and improving
care would you be amenable to a
different amendment
that
opens up the bill
opens up the study committee's
jurisdiction i mean to
also look into things like allowing
portability of health care plans direct
primary care physicians
a la carte insurance and
and and some of these other types of
issues so that it's not just
narrow to this we do have every year we
have this the
bill that comes up saying let people buy
health insurance across state lines but
there are quite a few things that kind
of have to get looked at by a study
committee before they come come to uh
the commerce committee i
think if i understand your question
correctly my answer would be those are
all reasonable potential solutions so
absolutely we can amend this to explore
those possibilities again the end
objective is to bring down cost to
consumer and so those are clearly ways
that can be that can be done so yes we
could uh
bring some more direction into this
particular study to find out whether
those are our reasonable solutions or
how to make those
work all right sure thing i'd answer
your question i guess i should does that
actually answer your question yes it
does
thank you
yeah representative patusik
uh
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative griezmann for taking my
question uh would you be amenable to
retaining this
and bringing it back next year with the
required amendments
working on it again next year
absolutely uh th this is uh this is how
are we gonna how are we gonna make it
work
so absolutely
thank you
okay i assume max you just still have
your hand up so is there any other
questions for representative greeson
the representative
clear okay yeah let's see if they heard
their hands somehow disappeared so
representative mcclaire
um
my question is you're talking about
buying insurance across state lines
you actually buy a product
where the insurance company is is not
allowed to do business in the state um
maybe that's the question for uh
tyler will speak on this bill
he is he's the only one signed up
actually
okay
i i will defer to his expertise i am not
an insurance uh guru so
although i do pay my premiums and grit
my teeth when i do
um well to be the chair's opinion that
um that for all of us the longer we stay
on this committee the more we'll be able
to get our arms around the the problems
and all the issues that are involved
here and
and that and and yes there are no simple
solutions if there were we would have
already applied them
okay uh tyler you're the only person
signed up to speak on this bill
um okay thanks actually what didn't know
i was signed um
oh no you're right you did you're right
no i'm sorry
take it back but nobody signed
all up so
maybe maybe just give a little
structural
conversation about the idea of buying
because the way that the title of the
bill is buying insurance from an
out-of-state company
so why don't you give everybody a little
feeling for how that's supposed to how
could or can't work or whatever
yeah so so sticking to the 30 000 foot
level we have a lot of companies that
are licensed in new hampshire um i think
it's in the thousands most of the
companies don't offer
health insurance products that are
approved
by the department and if they haven't
got a product that has been approved by
the department they're basically
prohibited from marketing the product in
the state
and it's a little more significant with
the federal exchange and we use were
federally facilitated exchange states so
while we approve products it's the
federal government's website so if you
put in new hampshire zip code you're not
going to see
a product that isn't approved in new
hampshire that being said there actually
isn't anything that prevents you
from buying a product that is sold in
another state in fact if you worked in
dc or if you worked for the most part in
another state then it might be a good
idea to buy an insurance product that
has a network there which lends itself
to what is usually the biggest issue
with a new territory for an insurance
company is developing a local network of
health care providers and that can be
challenging if you don't have a lot of
members because if you want to negotiate
with concord hospital or
dartmouth-hitchcock it's a lot easier to
do if you're a big company like anthem
and you're 40 of the commercially
insured people they treat if you're a
company they haven't heard of or even a
national company like united or retina
but you don't have much of a local
presence it's very difficult to
negotiate with those health care
providers locally so that tends to be
one of the larger barriers but but that
being said i think to the extent that
somebody might want to purchase an
insurance product that's in another
state i'm even thinking about new
hampshire residents that actually work
in massachusetts they might get their
insurance through blue cross and
massachusetts and that's another example
of how they actually have a an
out-of-state product
but that would be uh employer-provided
insurance right you couldn't get into
the non-group product in washington dc
you would have to be you'd have to be an
employer-sponsored program no as an
individual there's there's no new
hampshire law that prohibits a new
resident from buying one of those
products in their state obviously there
could be another state law that says you
can only sell it to somebody in their
state but um that would be more
restrictive than is typically the case i
think
right so so the key element is there's
not a law barring anybody from buying
across it it's just that would a company
out of state companies sell you
a product intentionally to new hampshire
and what you're saying is unless they
have built up a network or have some
agreements with some hospital they're
they're not going to offer you the
product
it might be a concern from a consumer
services point of view they wouldn't
want you to think that you could get
local access to a health care provider
so they they might do what they can to
discourage you from from buying their
product that being said i have heard
insurance companies say to to us that uh
you know they have they could go so far
as putting the skull and crossbones on
the product but uh if it's cheap enough
some people will buy it anyway and
they'll complain later
when they find out that they can't get
service locally
okay
uh representative abramson's next
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question um as i i've said
before in some of our other hearings um
i live in seabrook which is right on the
border with massachusetts and we have
about half of our people when they get
taken by the ambulance they either want
to go to
uh portsmouth or exeter the other half
want to go to anna jakes which is in
massachusetts if anna jakes were to set
up an hmo
or you have you have a number of health
providers in
um
in north shore massachusetts uh is there
something specifically that prevents
them from doing that right now
um they live in new hampshire
yeah yeah so there are a number of of
what are now federal requirements for
what the health insurance product needs
to
include and the essential health
benefits are an example of that but as
long as they are offering a a product um
they wanted to offer a product they
would have to be licensed insurer and a
lot of that has to do with solvency and
some of your traditional financial
measures but um but to have a health
insurance product they would just need
to demonstrate that they had all the
network adequacy components to it so i
think
i may be providing more detail than than
you're looking for but um they basically
have to be a licensed insurer they have
to offer a product that meets the
standards that are in this state network
adequacy probably being one of the
biggest hurdles um but uh but but no i
mean i i'm not maybe i'm missing the
point of your question i apologize if i
am
follow-up
certainly
so
uh
if they're currently getting their
health insurance coverage with a new
hampshire company but they're almost
always going to north shore providers or
to anna jakes is there an increased cost
associated with that if they have to go
out of state in order
to to see their doctor
yeah so there could be so it depends on
what network is offered to them and uh
if they're buying like an individual
product those individual products are
the products that tend to have the
narrowest networks because um it's it's
the carrier seal that's your most price
sensitive population whereas in the
group market you tend to have a more
robust network some of the the carriers
are well most of our
either regional or national carriers so
they do try to
work on more than just a state level to
give people access to providers in
another state under the contractual
arrangements that they might have there
it's a little different between new
hampshire and massachusetts because
you've got kind of anthem in new
hampshire and you've got blue cross blue
shield of massachusetts which is not an
anthem company but um there also is also
coordination between blue cross plans so
they can sometimes access at least some
of the contracts and the benefits of
going to an out-of-state provider so
depending on the actual product in the
company there may be flexibility to go
to those providers in massachusetts and
clearly if it's for specialized services
that are only going to be available
there that has to be offered in order to
meet the network adequacy requirements
we would have
in new hampshire
all right thank you yeah why don't you
describe what network adequacy means
okay yeah so there is a statute that
says
for an insurance product to be marketed
in new hampshire and the decision is
county by county then the network has to
have include providers that offer
services within a certain time and
distance so for every county there is an
analysis done as to whether or not there
are local primary care physical therapy
mental health services but on the other
end of the spectrum the carrier just
needs to ensure that very specialized
services are available within some
greater distance so for something like
knee surgery the proximity might not be
as close as something for like primary
care but if it's something like a very
specialized service the carrier could
have the only provider as one that's
available someplace in massachusetts or
connecticut but again these decisions
are made county by counties so
in new hampshire we're pretty lucky
because the carriers tend to have very
robust networks they include most of the
providers most of the hospitals and many
other states where they have perhaps
half the providers then it would be more
of an issue but um but to the extent a
carrier um has a network we actually
receive those networks we evaluate those
networks to see whether or not the the
services are available locally the
services that are spelled out in our
rule and
that's how we ensure sort of reasonable
access to health care services
okay
oh chris you got up from your nap uh
you ready to uh have a question
yes i do
um
my question is that uh number one uh i i
understand what tyler brennan is
explaining about robust networks and
that is a big problem if you're buying
trying to get cheaper insurance out of
from an out of state firm so you have
you have to understand the risks
involved
that you may end up
causing yourself
expenses anyway uh the and i also like
the idea of
a committee that would look at some
areas where we might be able to
uh improve
the uh health care here in the state uh
by state legislation and uh i mean i
i've read about uh doctors who
um are working in the state and they
negotiate all the pricing and and so
that's something that's
interests me and i'm sure it would fall
under what uh
mr greeson is thinking of in terms of
things that can be discussed that said
my question to mr greeson is one of the
most thoroughly investigated
and
debated
things that might reduce and improve
health care
are
universal universal healthcare for
example so i'm thinking if you're going
to have a discussion
about what might be improved here in the
state of new hampshire i would hope that
one of the
one of the items
that your your committee would discuss
is in fact single-payer healthcare and
uh and normally uh
the people you know normally that's
considered divisive
right by one of our parties and and you
know so they don't they don't like it so
they don't want anybody else to talk
about it
so i i would think that in in the with
the
idea of fairness and clarity
that we would discuss we would also have
this committee
uh
you know observe the
pros and cons
of uh a single-payer
or whatever you want to call it your
question is should he include
single-payer i'm yes
obviously and and if he he thinks that's
uh
i think in order to be fair the answer
should be well of course mr herbert
i i i will answer that question be
delighted to um
it's i i think of it as like this
there are those who believe in creation
and there are those who believe in
evolution
i have one position you may have another
position
you believe yours is right i believe
mine is right
if i thought that we studied it all out
and the answer was universal health care
if that was truly the end-all be-all
that that would bring all the the utopia
of low prices and everything like that
then
i guess that would be the solution to
the problem
however i do not believe that that is
the correct answer i believe that the
competition in the marketplace and
freedom of choices and things like that
uh and and and get get government
regulations and crony capitalism out of
the picture and bring it down to to more
of an individual level where people can
buy what they need to buy when they need
to buy it uh and then maybe have a
catastrophic insurance policy that would
cover the oops that we didn't weren't
expecting that one uh you know there are
there are there are numerous solutions
to that to the to this
and so
uh
we could explore
any number of options
but if we're going to be honest
whichever one is going to win out is the
one that wins out so we can't just go in
with preconceived notions and say well
by god this is the answer now let's make
the answer the solution and so i'll
corrupt all the data to show this is the
answer when that may not be the answer
and i don't care which side of this
political spectrum you're on if you're
going to fudge the data i won't support
you and so uh if i mean it is a solution
you put it out there uh let's explore it
but if that's not the solution then
that's not the solution and if if
something else that somebody else comes
up with is not the solution that's not
the solution we're here to find the
solution
uh
just
one observation
i'm 71 years old so i have medicare
and i can tell you
it works
take my word for it
and you spent your entire adult life
paying for it before you got the benefit
oh i got the benefit that's all i can do
it works well if i just say aren't you
what do you live to be 65 so you get the
benefit
oh well i would extend it to everybody
yeah
okay well uh this is actually the feels
like the very first year and almost a
good half a dozen years that we don't
have any single-payer legislation this
year this is we
i know representative kenner usually
puts something in but it's not coming
this way so no it has no chance
but all right with that uh we'll end the
public hearing on uh on house bill 4
and open up our last public hearing
on
house bill 592
and uh
greetson you're
invited to
make your presentation
well thank you mr chairman and i did go
in and sign up for it so i am officially
signed up now perfect
thank you committee members i am still
representative jeffrey greeson of
grafton county district 16. this is a
floaterial district that covers eight
towns from wentworth east to thornton
and south to canaan i'm introducing
house bill 592 as a means of providing
all new hampshire residents with
protection against injury caused by
vaccinations
nothing about this bill should be
considered anti-vaccine
i have been vaccinated my two children
were vaccinated my five grandchildren
have been vaccinated i respect those who
choose not to be vaccinated equally as i
respect those who choose to be
vaccinated this bill provides everyone
who chooses to receive any vaccine with
a means of being compensated at least in
part if they should be harmed by a
vaccine because it does happen
advancements in medicine have resulted
in vaccines being developed that have
helped minimize the effects and the
spread of some of the deadliest viruses
ever to plague this planet so there is
value to vaccines but as with every
medicine or vaccine there are potential
risks no vaccine or medicine is 100
percent effective and some people will
experience significant side effects even
death
the national institutes for health state
that more than 1.5 million people are
hospitalized every year because quote
adverse drug reactions meaning side
effects from medications and
approximately 100 000 patients die from
drug side effects
according to 42 u.s codes subsection 300
double attack 22
no vaccine manufacturers shall be liable
in a civil action for damages arising
from a vaccine-related injury or death
associated with the administration of a
vaccine after october 1 1988. if the
injury or death resulted from side
effects that were unavoidable even
though the vaccine was properly prepared
and was accompanied by proper directions
and warnings
the national vaccine injury compensation
program was subsequently developed to
handle vaccine injury claims because
vaccine injuries do happen according to
the federal health resources and
services administration uh in those
instances when people experience more
serious side effects from vaccines such
as allergic reactions the national
vaccine injury compensation program
allows individuals to file a petition
for compensation the process is
a typical government process about five
steps where first of all the individual
files a petition with the u.s court of
federal claims then the u.s department
of health and human services medical
staff reviews that petition determines
if it meets the medical criteria for
compensation and makes a preliminary
recommendation
then the u.s department of justice
develops a report that includes the
medical recommendation and legal
analysis and submits it to the court
after that the report is presented to a
court appointed special master that's
the title that they're given who decides
whether the petitioner should be
compensated and often after holding a
hearing in which both parties can
present evidence then if compensation is
awarded that special master determines
the amount and the type of compensation
the court then orders the united states
department of health and human services
to award the compensation uh and even if
the petition is dismissed in certain
circumstances the court may order that
the department pay for attorney's fees
and costs
uh
in and and looking at how many uh
petitions have actually been awarded
compensation between 2006 when they
began including influenza
influenza vaccines uh and and 2018 which
is the latest data i could find on the
on the uh
the
website of the health resources services
administration
uh between 2006 and 2018 there were 5
351 compensable claims out of 23 619
claims filed and a total of 2.2 billion
dollars was awarded to petitioners
during that time attorney's fees were
additional to that 2.2 billion
so far excuse me in 2020 734 claims were
paid totaling 187 million dollars and so
far in 2021 73 million dollars have been
paid to 196 petitioners
is there risk that uh vaccine
manufacturers would discontinue selling
their products if they if this bill were
to be signed into law and they would
have to put up the bond etc i guess
anything is possible but history does
not show that to be likely
as of december 2020 lawsuits were
underway across the country against the
makers of zantac evandia several acid
reflux medications in fact i was able to
find 58 products that have lawsuits
currently underway
for which settlements have recent or
either lawsuits are currently underway
or settlements have recently been made
yet despite these lawsuits most of these
products are still readily available in
the states in which those suits occurred
just a few years ago the state of new
hampshire sued several manufacturers of
various opioid medications including
teva pharmaceuticals johnson and johnson
purdue pharma and several others and yet
many of those companies still do
business in new hampshire and you can
still get those opioid medications now
it is should be noted that purdue pharma
is no longer in business as they decided
to close after filing bankruptcy
subsequent to pleading guilty to three
federal criminal charges but that's not
the same as product liability
in 2019 the state of new hampshire sued
teva pharmaceuticals and others in an
anti-trust lawsuit interestingly tava
pharmaceuticals usa incorporated with a
principal address in parsippany new
jersey is also registered as a new
hampshire foreign profit corporation
filed on march 18 2020 that's after
being sued and their address is in
bedford new hampshire their filing
status is listed as good standing and
its file number is 83819
the state of new hampshire has also sued
the manufacturers of other products and
yet they continue to do business in the
state in 2012 the state of new hampshire
received a portion of 4 billion dollar
settlement with several cigarette
manufacturers can you still buy
cigarettes in the state of new hampshire
yes you can in fact we are celebrating
the the increase in revenue
to the state because massachusetts
banned menthol flavored cigarettes
so here you have a company that was sued
uh and yet they do business in the state
and the state is happy about them
selling their products
so what this legislation does is hold
these companies accountable for the
vaccines that they sell just like every
other product they sell and every other
product made by every other company just
without the lawsuits the lengthy time
delays and without tarnishing their
reputations this does not interfere with
anyone's options in filing a claim with
the the federal vicp program it provides
a means of making those who have been
harmed as whole as possible as quickly
as possible since most people will not
experience any harm from vaccines the
number of claims should be low but those
few people who are harmed can receive
some compensation no money can replace
the life of a loved one some people are
not going to be made completely whole
but at the very least they are not being
carelessly told suck it up
claims will be initiated by the
patient's doctor who will determine that
the vaccine was the cause of harm and
this harm must have been determined to
occur within two weeks of the
vaccination the pharmaceutical companies
state that most side effects especially
excuse me the severe effects would occur
within that two weeks vaccination uh so
that's the window that's where i where
that two weeks comes from
one last thought it should be noted that
hb 20 currently being uh in the
legislature which is the education
freedom account bill requires a surety
bond for education service providers
receiving more than one hundred thousand
dollars in efa funds so the drafters of
that legislation are not concerned that
potential education service providers
will simply refuse to do business in the
state of new hampshire because they
would have to put up a bond that's all i
have for now i'm open for questions
okay
uh representative
van outen has a question thank you mr
chair and and thank you representative
um there was just a whole lot there uh
so let me just cut to the quick
um toward the end you just alluded uh to
this toward the end in roman four
you indicate that this will be done by
the diagnosis of illness and
determination that the illness is
directly linked to the vaccine by a
physician do you think you're asking too
much of a physician to be able to come
to that determination
isn't that what a doctor is supposed to
do
follow please
oh yes for the question you inquire
uh my question is i don't know a doctor
is supposed to diagnose illness and
things of that sort i agree with you
there's not a problem there but to
diagnose that uh an illness is directly
linked to the vaccine
may in my opinion is is likely to go
beyond the purview of doctor do you not
agree with that
i do not agree with that because they
determined that lung cancer can be
caused by smoking and that's where all
those lawsuits came from
and an individual physician i know i'm
sorry follow-up please
hear the question
uh an individual like my individual
physician would be able to diagnose that
and say that if i were a smoker my lung
disease was directly related i and
actually i think i'll withdraw the
question i think perhaps where we're
going in divergent directions i
appreciate your input thank you
representative herbert
um thank you
can you hear me yes we can okay
um
thanks thanks thanks for letting me uh
ask the question and uh thank you uh
representative griezmann i like the idea
of uh posting a bond
and uh and the fact is uh
and you had a lot of statistics but
those were a lot of that stuff was uh
was not vaccine related it was other
other problems that arose
for instance for cigarettes and that
kind of thing but uh
and i don't know
my question is
i like the idea but
did
i my understanding is uh
bad things from uh taking a vaccine are
fairly rare
did you see any statistics
you i couldn't keep up with you on your
statistics so i was just wondering is
was there some statistics you had there
that that said if you took a vaccine
x number of people died or or sued or
that kind of thing i i what i what i do
have and what i shared and i'll share
again is uh with with just the claims
filed now this is just claims filed
uh 23 619 claims have have been filed
through the uh the federal visit program
uh
and 5 351 were found to be compensable
claims
um
so that's that is just based just on
their numbers they have acknowledged uh
23 619 these are all just vaccine injury
claims
uh there are there there may have uh
there may be others people who just
chose not to because of the cumbersome
process uh but they uh
yes overall
uh the the number of vaccine injuries is
relatively small uh but that's not the
point the fact is that they do occur
and so
this is uh their this is a way of
dealing with when they do occur uh
everyone alive today uh that's before me
has probably had a vaccine i'm assuming
and maybe not uh has received some sort
of vaccine you're still alive today you
did not have an injury or i assume you
didn't have an injury so we're living
testimonies that you can receive
vaccines and not be injured
but there are those who clearly do uh
suffer injuries and and even just just
so far this year we are on the
34th day of the year
and uh and so far over 73 million
dollars have been paid out to almost 200
petitioners and so they're happening
these injuries are occurring
and
so this is this is uh taking care of
those people just one more question
you might um
the uh thanks for the stat uh and i
don't disagree with you by the way in
terms of posting a bond but of the
statistics you have quoted
and and we're undergoing a
massive
massive vaccination program uh but how
many of those stats right now have come
out of covid19
vaccines
uh none of the statistics that i have
shared the thus far are coveted vaccine
uh injuries uh co the cobit vaccine is
an unusual animal in fact it is not
actually considered it is not an actual
fda approved vaccine it is actually an
experimental medical therapy that has
been authorized and being administered
under emergency use authorization
and so and to try to get compensation
for any injuries from that is a much
more difficult process
so
the covet vaccine is completely
different uh there there
but just
from the numbers that i have shared with
you that would be things like the the
influenza
to
dtp to whatever else
the normal vaccinations not including
kobe
finally
no
is there a way is there a way we can uh
ask whether or not the bond would
create problems with sales
is there a way of finding out the answer
to that question
well i you know
are they gonna
i don't know how to find out that that's
why i brought up the fact that uh
uh
you know this the state of new hampshire
uh has sued
manufacturers uh well pharmaceutical
companies first of all it's because it's
you know pharmaceutical companies
manufacturing the vaccines and
pharmaceutical companies manufacture
other medications and so we can sue
pharmaceutical companies because of
their medical their their medications
and the liabilities and injuries
associated with that
but for some reason we can't sue
the same pharmaceutical companies for
their vaccines
and so
they still do business in the state
despite being sued
and so uh so it's i think it's it's it's
just not legitimate to think that we
can't hold them accountable well they'll
just pack up and go home uh they won't
do business with us because we're gonna
hold them accountable so the the bond is
is in lieu of any kind of legis or um
litigation
uh
and and again the idea of bringing up hb
20 is is because that bill is calling
for a bond as well
and so
uh you know putting up a bond and and
holding people accountable the
liabilities and such like that is not an
unreasonable request or in this case a
reasonable demand and so
yes there's a risk that they would just
not do business in the state but i just
don't see that happening because there's
other other issues
they can be held accountable for
everything else
thank you
okay representative abramson has a
question
all right thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question on this
one i absolutely agree 100 with the
intent of
of the bill
um
my concern is not with it with the
structure of the bill or what its intent
is but i'm wondering what happens when a
company decides to stop
either stop selling that vaccine or that
vaccine gets uh superseded by another
product in the marketplace
um
is there a provision for kind of getting
the bond back or getting the letter back
from the insurance
uh commissioner is that just uh is that
implied
are you saying that if if
they're selling the selling a vaccine
for
um
malaria or or some other
provision and someone some other
competing company comes by with a better
vaccine product
and this company stopped selling the
product the old vaccine on the on the
marketplace
would
what would happen with that that company
are they are they getting the bond back
uh
this bill does not actually address that
because that's not be honestly that was
not something that i had considered uh
that they would
they would just stop
i apologize for that i actually did not
even think about that being the case but
uh they should get their their bond the
balance would ever be it would ever be
remaining uh because the claims would be
paid out of that uh and then they would
have to refresh that uh to maintain that
balance but at the end uh if there was
anything
then they should get that back yes
but that's just that's not in the bill
though no
okay i have a follow-up further question
inquiry uh this one's a would you
believe it's my first would you believe
of the day that i did do some
uh research on the federal vaccine
injury fund and that it's only paying
out
uh at six percent rate only six percent
of the claims and they have a maximum of
two hundred fifty thousand dollars per
payout most people don't get the 250 000
even if they have a relative who've died
from vaccine injury
i do believe that because i looked up at
the same information and you are correct
all right thank you very much okay learn
something new every day all right
representative abel
yes thank you and thank you uh
representative greeson for uh for
testimony and for answering our
questions
um i've got a question
about
whether
the state legislature
or
is the right
place for this
kind of legislation or whether it needs
to be federal because i believe
most of most of uh the examples you gave
us
dealt with the federal uh federal
oversight and federal uh uh
reimbursement or or uh
paying a paying for debt for damages
at the very beginning
of your uh of your uh testimony i know
you said something about the state and
state law but i kind of missed that and
so in addition to telling me why this
should be in the state
in state legislation could you say again
what you said about state uh
state laws that apply to this i i'm
sorry i just didn't get all of that
well
presently no state law addresses this
that's why this is being introduced
federal law 42 u.s code subsection 300
double a attack 22
says that no manufacturer no vaccine
manufacturer shall be liable in a civil
action for damages arising from a
vaccine-related injury or death
associated with the administration of a
vaccine after october 1st 1988
and so
the the fact that they cannot be held
liable in a civil action
if you go in and look at the national
vaccine injury compensation program
it does actually allow
that if the special master's decision
may be appealed and petitioners who
reject the decision of the court or
withdraw their petitions within certain
timeliness
they may file a claim in civil court
against the vaccine company and or
health care provider who administered
the vaccine
so the federal law actually does allow
for
at some point in time a vaccine company
to be a civil action against them and or
the health care provider who
administered the vaccine to be held
accountable
so that's where the federal law allows
but that process is hugely cumbersome
could this be
taken at the at the at the federal level
i suppose if you vote for me for u.s
senate in 2022 uh i could present it at
that level uh but as it stands right now
i'm just little old me at uh
representative greeson from grafton 16
and putting it before the state of new
hampshire house of representatives
uh follow up please another question yep
yes um
now you muted yourself
that mouse is really
i know this mouse this mouse is alive
how's track
it's a house trap thank you um
my understanding is that
when the state
law and federal law
uh may differ
or contradict
uh one another
that state that federal law has
takes the fir you know takes the higher
uh
higher position
um
and
so i i'm just
again i'm just questioning
uh whether uh a state law to this effect
would would
uh
would have any
any value um
would you would you try to persuade me
that it does
well this is not a lawsuit
this is not civil action
there's no court involved this is
legislation saying
that we we are going to establish this
uh uh the ability to compensate those
who have been injured and
the the source of funding for that
compensation because it's specifically
two people injured by vaccines
the source of funding would come put up
by the vaccine manufacturers
uh so
that's this is not civil suit this is
not litigation in any way this is just
this is we're establishing a fund and
you're gonna pony up
okay
uh see representative uh
fargo is next
um yes thank you mr chair
um i guess i'm struggling with this a
little bit japan and i understand where
you're coming from but i know as an
individual when i get a vaccine i go to
my physician
i
he tells me what my risks are i signed a
paper that said i accept those risks and
i choose to have that vaccine
so on an individual level um i'm
accepting that risk i can understand i
guess if if
a large group of people had an adverse
reaction to a vaccine that there would
be a full you know one suit of a lot of
people but i don't understand on an
individual basis
um if i'm if i'm signing that i accept
the risk why uh why this is necessary
well any uh anytime you sign a risk
waiver does not necessarily mean that
the person uh
that that
there's still not some means of
compensating any injury
as bizarre as it sounds do you have
homeowners insurance
sure
well did you know that somebody can
break into your home in the in the
process of committing a crime
injure themselves in your home while
committing a crime
and then sue your homeowner's insurance
policy you could you could file a claim
and they would win
they would be compensated it's happened
before you're shaking your head miss
barley i'm new hampshire
and yes and so um signing signing
waivers does not necessarily mean uh
that there's no avenue uh to be taken uh
and so
uh
i understand you're accepting the risks
we all accept those risks but there's
still something that can be done
thank you okay you're all set and
representative terry
thank you mr chairman representative
greeson thank you
uh for for your work in this area
um uh i have just a very simple question
i i hope are you aware of like or
similar efforts being introduced in any
other of the state legislatures
yes it's the solo effort
i'm not aware of anything in any other
state
are you i if you are then then we could
certainly uh that was that was not a
loaded question um
no i'm not aware of anything
okay
all right well thank you very much uh
this conversation has uh invited someone
to want to testify so paula minihan from
the hospital association
would like to help
clarify this issue for us
you still there paula
i am um but sorry i was um i'm sorry
about that maybe i hit the computer
incorrectly i was wanting to clarify on
the last bill um
or that billed two bills before i think
so sorry oh okay never mind then
yeah sorry i i was just trying to
address the question that representative
abramson had um relative to the self-pay
and how that actually works but you've
be you've moved beyond so sorry about
that okay oh thank you all right so uh
you have one more speaker um who signed
up for this bill is nick doherty
so go ahead nick
i just want can everyone hear me
okay thank you i do thank you to the
members of the committee uh to
give me this opportunity to to join you
virtually today
so my name is nick doherty i'm the
director of policy pharma for the new
england region and i am based out of
boston
pharma is the pharmaceutical research
and manufacturers of america and we
represent the country's leading
innovative biopharmaceutical research
companies which are devoted
to discovering and developing medicines
that enable patients to live longer
healthier and more productive lives and
since 2000 farm remember companies have
invested nearly one trillion dollars
in search for new treatment and cures
including an estimated 83 billion in
2019 alone
now as mentioned i'm here to testify on
house bill 592.
i i believe we've had a pretty spirited
conversation up to this point don't need
to rehash
the contents of the bill but pharma is
opposed for two reasons
first the legislation is preempted by
existing federal law and second the
language raises due process concerns for
vaccine manufacturers
now the statement that we did submit to
the committee provides more detail about
the federal laws already in place and
that do address the compensation for
individuals
and for the sake of time i'll i'll
address the general ideas here i think
there's a lot of good coverage so far
but do want to point out there's two
programs that are established in
existing federal law that specifically
address compensation related to vaccine
injuries
now the first one is the public
readiness and emergency preparedness act
now the prepped act as it's called is
used during public health emergencies
such as the one we're in right now with
covid19
and this gives the secretary of hhs the
authority to limit legal liability for
losses
relating to the administration of
countermeasures such as
diagnosis treatment and vaccines
related to the emergency now should an
individual be harmed by one of those
countermeasures
that individual may pursue a claim from
the covered counter-measure process fund
and that's a fund that's authorized
under the prepped act
and the second one which uh the sponsor
of the bill did cover is the national
childhood vaccine injury act
and this covers many if not most of
other vaccines and does include a
federally administered compensation
system for individuals that are injured
after receiving a vaccine from one of
the drugs covered under the act
now both of these federal statutes
expressly preempt state law claims
that would result in inconsistencies
with the federal law
so rep able to ask that question
the federal law does uh is explicit that
it has the ultimate authority on um
overseeing
these compensation programs
and and the final point we bring up is
that the bill does raise due process
concerns under both the united states
and new hampshire constitutions because
it does not provide procedural
protections for vaccine manufacturers
such as a mechanism for challenging a
physician's claim
based upon
as as drafted
so very quickly those are the the
reasons outlined
that we would respectfully urge the
legislators on this committee to to
oppose house bill 592 and happy to try
to answer any questions
uh i
don't see any questions from the members
so thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you um and i do see two hands up
in attendees um
so i guess we'll let i will
the nice guy that i am i'll let them
speak
so uh thomas
mcleod
these testifiers did um
register late you know after we printed
the list
you know i was thinking that we should
probably do the afternoon ones at you
know at lunchtime maybe we should be
doing that i know yeah we did that some
days or maybe last week and and today i
did them all
right yes
all right yes so thomas go ahead and
introduce yourself and
tell us where you are on this issue
yes uh thank you mr chairman my name is
tom thomas mccloud i am a resident of
mount vernon new hampshire
i am the chair of the liberty defense
fund in new hampshire and the member of
the leadership group of health freedom
new hampshire today i am testifying as a
member of the public
and thank you for hearing my testimony
mr chairman in america today vaccine
injury is a serious problem that has
touched an increasing number of citizens
in new hampshire and throughout the
country
before the present pandemic vaccine
injury was primarily a concern of
parents of younger children
who continue to face tremendous medical
and legal obstacles to recognition
treatment and compensation of injuries
to children too young to speak for
themselves
these parents have routinely faced
denial from medical professionals and
unjust criticism in the media
however since the advent of the
coronavirus vaccine
adults too are experiencing
injuries and they are able to speak from
them for themselves as we have seen in
recent widespread media coverage of
adverse reactions to the pfizer vaccine
mr chairman
federal law currently does preempt state
courts from hearing product liability
claims against
vaccine manufacturers since the
national childhood vaccine injury act
first shielded pharmaceutical companies
in 1988 the total number of vaccines
recommended for children has increased
from five vaccines for nine diseases to
currently 12 vaccines for 16 diseases
not including any upcoming
recommendation for the coronavirus
vaccine
as of 2020 the total compensation of
injury and death that the federal
vaccine court has awarded is
approximately 4.9 billion dollars
parents must sue the federal government
in the special court to have any hope of
compensation
awards come from a fund based on
a vaccine excise tax and not from the
vaccine manufacturers themselves
due to procedural and jurisdictional
impediments less than 10 percent of
injuries ever come before the court
even then compensation can take 10 years
or more
placing tremendous burden on families
as burdensome as this process is for
the recommended childhood vaccines any
coronavirus vaccine adverse event cannot
come before this court
borough law designates all so-called
coven 19 vaccines as quote emergency
countermeasures quote and thus such
adverse results are essentially exempt
from compensation under the federal prep
act
to respond briefly to previous testimony
on the liability of manufacturers
though the 1986
national childhood vaccine injury act
does appear to provide
an avenue to the courts
the holding of the 2012 u.s supreme
court decision in bristol where it's
bertha wyeth essentially bars all claims
against manufacturers for the design
defects
in the pro product liability case
uh mr chairman i logged the intent
behind this bill to return some
liability for injuries back to where it
squarely belongs
that is the manufacturers themselves and
i commend the sponsor representative
greeson for his courage in bringing
forth an attempt to proactively address
one of the most
intractable and divisive issues of our
time
however i fear this
specific approach of this bill
the compensation out of a manufacturer's
bond would face immediate challenge
based on federal preemption
and thus provide a false sense of hope
uh to the injureds and their grieving
families furthermore the bill
charges physicians with determining the
existence of an adverse reaction but
provides no standard by which to make
such a determination
for these reasons i urge further study
of this approach and neither support nor
oppose hb 592
and i'll take any questions if anyone on
the committee has any
great thank you
representative abramson has a question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you mr
mcleod for taking my question um you
said that the
vaccine injury program is what includes
the federal preemption does that prevent
uh
states from taking some type of action
uh requiring insurance or
or
posting a bond or other other measures
the acts
explicitly prevents
state
product liability claims uh product
liability claims in state court as to
this particular
mechanism of payment out of a bond it i
don't think it's directly addressed
but um my
uh
opinion at this time without having
thoroughly studied it is that
the act would
constructively preempt
this type of arrangement
but it does require further study
great thank you all right thank you very
much for your testimony thank you and so
we have one other person and i'm going
to move him john john b all right uh
promote to panelists
and
go ahead
cameron you can hear me yes we can very
good i thank you my name is john martin
i'm the deputy chief legal counsel for
the department of health human services
the department has not taken a position
on house bill 592 but it has identified
a couple of concerns that i wanted to
bring to your attention under the bill
claims against the bond would be filed
with the commissioner of the department
of health human services and this
department doesn't believe that it is
the appropriate entity to hear these
claims
believes that these types of liability
claims are more appropriate for a court
of
law also we're concerned about the
potential for a fraud this bill requires
only that a physician state that a
patient became ill as a result of
receiving a vaccine it's unclear under
the bill how these claims would actually
be verified
moreover there's a pretty quick
turnaround time for the commissioner to
pay the patient a patient's
representative once a claim has been
filed which we're concerned doesn't
allow sufficient time for the claim to
be looked into and and verified
so those are our concerns and i just
wanted to bring those to your attention
i muted myself
okay so is there anybody else would like
to uh oh we have a couple of questions
uh representative abramson you can go
ahead sorry let's try taking that down
okay so uh jeff unfortunately it's you
testified you can't ask ask a question
in a public heart so
all righty
i guess that's it and i have no more
hands up so we're all set
so i will close the the public hearing
and
i would say that uh there were um in
this bill there were two opposition and
11 members of the public that were in
support of the bill
and with that um i will
end our session today and see you all oh
yeah representative bartlett